よろしくお願いします
えっと 今日はまあまとまりのないテーマですけど
まあどこまで喋るか 喋ればいいかっていう
なんかガイドラインはつけられない話にはなってますけど
ブッダからの贈り物というブッダの贈り物
で 悟った人がもたらす恩恵というのは何なのかと
話始まる前に 一応 お釈迦様が我々には大変大事な贈り物を残してあるということで
贈り物だったら プレゼントだったら
それは当然喜ばれるものなんですね
で 問題はこれはとんだ贈り物ですかと
ということなんです  で
このポイントを考えたのはそういうわけなんですね
いくらお釈迦様の教えを紹介しても
まあそんなのは嫌だ 嫌いだと
やりたくはないんだという反応を起こすんですね
ということは お釈迦様の言葉に対しては
これがすごい まあとんだ贈り物ではないかという考え方はあるんです
で それについてどうかなと
考えてみたいと思います
えーと  ブッダというのは悟った方で
悟り開いて説法をしたんですね
で 悟ってすぐは こんなのはもう言ってもみんなに迷惑だという必要はないんじゃないかと
ともお釈迦様は思ったんですね
だから 皆様 今更こんなのは嫌やと思っても
お釈迦様はすぐ先にそれわかっていたんです
誰よりも先に ですから
なんかすごいことを言ってるわけがなりません
どうせわかりっこはないんだと
どうせみんなやるわけじゃないんだと
というところでも 最初からもう捨てられているんです
お釈迦様に 欲に溺れて
無知に溺れて 苦しみに溺れて
瞬間でもそれから立ち上がろうというね
何のも一からそういう気持ちも何もないんだと
いわゆるまあ処分決定
廃車決定したような生き方ですよ
そこをまたゴミ箱にもうゴミに廃車決定しているものね
また修理して復活しようと
それよりはもう捨てた処分した方が清々するんじゃないかっていうことで
結構厳しいんですよ 態度は
だからこの今からね そんな話はもう当てにならんとかね
現代我々にはもう我々は知識人であって
科学世界で生きているのであって
もう素晴らしい世界を築いてあって
こんな古い話はもう通じませんということを言っても
あまりシャレにならないんですよ
これはもう 2600年で
どうせゴミやと言われているんだから
だからそれでやっぱりプライドを持ってチャレンジしなくちゃいけないんですね
本当に私たちはまあ そんなにも見込みのない捨てられた人間かと
あるいはブッダより我々はすごいことをやってるんですかと
すごい知識 私たちにはあるんですかと
お釈迦様に勝てるぐらいの
ということにチャレンジしなくちゃいけない
それは私一人でできることではありませんだけど
皆さんは世の中にあるあらゆる哲学
あらゆる宗教を勉強してみたら
何でもいいんですよ 全ての知識を世の中にある
知り尽くしてみたらどうですかね
それとお釈迦様の一言葉と比べてみる
どちらの方がすごいことを言ってるんでしょうかと
矛盾のない話をしているんでしょうかと
だからそれは全部できないんだから
私は散々的にあっちこっちから例を出しますけどね
これまたなかなかね まあ気に入られないんですよ
それはなぜかと自分で勉強していないんですね
それはもう私のせいにするんです
そんな話はもう意味がないやとかね
勉強してみれば 私は突然どこから引用するかわからないんです
今すごく混同していますよ
突然どこからでも引っ張ります
でも それは全然理解しないということをわかってからは
ものすごく自己管理はしています
しかし 話としてはね そんなにも深みがなくなるんですね
ただ日常茶飯事のことばっかり喋ると
まあそういう とにかくそういうことで
本当にお釈迦様っていうのはすごいことを教えたかと
で 私たちは釈尊の智慧に打ち勝っているんですかと
釈尊に説かれた道よりは優れた道を我々は発見しているんですかと
もう科学はいとかくもなかった時代のブッダでしょうに
ですから まあ今すごいことを知っているでしょ
世の中は では本当にそうでしょうかと
それで考えなくちゃいけない
それでお釈迦様の贈り物
贈り物っていうのは こんなのはとんだものやと
もう役に立たんと いらんと迷惑やと
なんかお歳暮を中間にもらってる
何でしたっけ？なんとか乾燥みたいな感じで
そのまま包装したまんまで置いておくものかと
断れなく まあありがとう
まあありがとうございますと受け取って
そのまま回しちゃうんですね
また店に 包装も開けてみないという
で そんなようなものかということは考えなくてはいけないんです
要は あの 今日はたくさんことありますけど
ほんの一部だけスライドに作ってみたんです
1枚目  1枚目ください
で まず仏教の立場を説明します
で 人間にとって幸福っていうのは悟りなんです
それ以外は何の幸福もあるはずがないという立場を仏教は取っています
それだったら これは本当かと
だったら皆様方は悟りって何なのかで勉強しなくちゃいけないんです
それは私は教えません
今日は で これダンマパダの引用なんですけど
98番目 ガーメーワヤディワーランジェニンネーワヤディワータレ
ヤッタアラハントーヴィーラアンティタンブーミンラーマネイヤカン
で こちらで言っているのは悟りすごいということじゃないんです
ガーメ 村であろうと ヤディワーランジェ
森の森であろうとも 村であっても
全く人が住んでない森の真ん中であろうとも
ニンネーワヤディワータレ
ニンネっていうのは あの
あの 山の間にある この
なんて言いますか あれは
谷 谷であろうと 谷っていうのは平らなところであろうと
いわゆるまあ場所のことを言ってるんですよ
生活しやすいところであろうか
生活しにくいところであろうか
あるいは人が住んでいる
いるところであろうか
いないところであろうか
やったアラハント ヴィヘランテ
そちらにアラハント 悟った人がヴィヘランテ住んでいるならば
タンブーミー その土地さえもラーマネーヤカ
とても美しい 素晴らしいものであると
ラーマネーヤカっていうのは
人間が行って喜ぶべき
まあ遊園地みたいなものなんです
人間に楽しみ 幸福を与えてくれるところだと
だから 悟りのところじゃなくて
悟った人がいる場所さえも人間に限りのない幸福を与えてくれる楽園なんです
で そこからの仏教っていうのは
まあもう皆様の思考からはまあ変わっていくんです
人間考えると 楽園っていうのは死んでからもらうもんですよ
だから待っていてください
死んだらもらえます どーんと
あの 何といいますか 究極に幸福に満たしている楽園
極楽道というもの で 口開けて待っていればいいんです
だから仏教はすごい具体的なことを喋るんです
で そんなにも死んでからはね
極楽道みたいな楽園があるんだから
早く死ねばいいでしょうに
だから それ信じる人々は 1日でも生きる
生き延びる 生きてること自体がわけのわからないバカバカらしいんですよ
1日でも早く究極な幸福を得ればいいでしょ
もう死ねばもらうんだから
もう永遠の楽園は だったら早く死ねばいいでしょ
論理的に考えると もっと能力ある体力ある人だったら
みんな人類を殲滅させちゃう
化学兵器であろうが 生物兵器であろうが
もう何でもいいんです
それで一発で地球を爆破させてしまって
もう人類はないことにする
で 前に警告を鳴らして
まあこれからみんなもう地球爆発しますから
みんなもう楽園を目指してお祈りしなさいと
それほどいいことないでしょうに
なんで殺して もうもう泣きながら喧嘩しながら文句言いながらもう生きているんですかね
だから まあそこをその時点からも仏教は論理的なことを喋ってるんですよ
矛盾だらけ いい加減なことを言うなよと
本当に死後に究極な楽園あるならば
早く死ねという論理でしょうに
現代 それで生きてる人々はいますよ
あの この自爆テロをやっている人々とか
しっかりしていますよ
自分の教えに従って  18歳であろうが
14歳であろうが その若い女の子たちは
男たちが体に爆弾いっぱいつけて
どこかにぶつけて死んで
それでもう天国には自分たちには特別なところがあるんだと
普通の人間が行くところよりももっといいところがあるんだよ
だったら早く行けばいいっていうことで頑張っているんです
その人々だけ論理的に生きて行動しているのに
なんでこの世界はその自爆テロをする人々に文句を言うんですかね
とんでもない話ですよ
そういうジハードというね
まあ聖戦というかね それで自分で体に爆弾つけて
もう他人も殺して自分も死ぬ人々っていうのはすごく論理的なんですよ
どうせ行くんだったら早く行った方がいいと
ですから そのには世の中っていうのは文句を言うのはあまりちょっと理屈に合わない
それだけじゃないんですよ
それでこの残されたお母さんとかね
お父さんとか ものすごく困窮するんですよ
自分で子供を自爆するために
お祭りをして見送って
それから胸を叩きながら泣くんです
あれって何やと これはすごくイランで見たんで
イランの昔ね そんなこと言うとみんな嫌われますけどね
ちょっと世界も知っておいた方がいいと思いますけど
で ある人にはなんで私の話はなかなか理解しないかとか
あんただと例やと 要はもういろんな外国からあれこれと
そんなのはもう興味ないんだと
それを考えてみればね
自分の家のこと以外興味ないというのは素晴らしいですね
まあでもそれだけでは証拠不十分ですよ
喋るためには 気持ちはわかってますけど
私にはどうすることもできないんです
今言ってるポイントにも日本ではあれはないんですからね
だからイランで戦争があった時は
イランとかいろんなところと一緒に
だからもう 14歳ぐらいの子供たちをね
選んで あなたは選び 選ばれましたと
神様特別に それで親たちが舞い上がって喜んで祭をして
子供を軍隊に送るんですよ
送って その子はもう 1週間 2週間で訓練を受けて
何の訓練もないんです
あのデトネーションっていうのは
爆弾はどうやってデトネートするかっていうのは
何て言いますか デトネートっていうのは
爆発させる 爆発させる
これだけ学ぶんですよ
これはまあ 子供だったらね
もうもう日本で学ぶんだからね
悪いことだったら頭すごいいいんですよ
勉強するのは ですから
このそれで行って死んでしまうでしょ
あるいは戦闘に送ったりもする
それで遺体を持って帰ったら
父親と母親がもう泣くわ
号泣するわ 崩れるわ 胸叩くわ
それで絶対許さないんだと
こういうことはとかね
また怒りに苦しむは あれって何ですかと
それが現代人なんですよ
そういう風なこの考え方を持って
仏教に文句言ったっても
ちょっと早すぎなんです
仏教はすごく具体的に物事を見ているんです
厳密に 論理的に だから論理的に生きることは何が悪いんですかと
変な迷信に基づいて生きていると
今我々生きている不安な平和は全くもない生き方なんですよ
それでお釈迦様が言うのはもう天国と極楽堂と
あるいは楽園というならば
悟った人がいる場所やと
場所さえも楽園だと この場合ははっきりと悟った人のことうんぬんやと言ってないんです
例えば ある死海みたいな
すごい 全くも人のまぐれなら
すごい森の中でも一人の悟った人が住んでるんだったら
その森自体 その山自体
楽園なんです これ昔は本当にそうでしたから
そういう心の波動っていうのは並のものじゃないんです
いただけで その地方には何の不幸も出てこないんです
洪水も自然災害もいただけで
その地方には 不幸も出てこないんです
洪水も自然災害も何も現れません
伝染病も何一つ いただけ
いるだけ それぐらい悟った人の威力っていうのはすごいものなんです
もう動物さえものすごく喜ぶんです
普通の人 森に入ったらもう動物に嫌がらせ
嫌がらせでしょ 動物の嫌がらせっていうのは結構大変だからね
別に人間殺したくはないんだけど
追い出そうとする だからまあ動物は自分の能力で追い出そうと
これは人間の命になっちゃいますけど
逃げられないし 走れないし
木を登れないし 人間というのはもうもうもう最悪状態ですからね
逃げれば追っかけてこないんですよ
だからしかし 悟った人にはどこにでも住めるんです
このすごい怖いと思っている動物たちでも
まあなんのことなくそこら辺にうろうろしたり
で 寝込んだり 勝手に出て
なんて言いますか 番犬やったりとかするんです
野生の動物は勝手に番犬やっちゃうと
人間にはなかなか近寄れないんですけど
そういうケースというのは
もう歴史の中でいくらでもあります
だから悟った方はいる場所さえも楽園であると
ということで はい 次のスライド
で また同じ法句経の言葉で
須候ブッダハナムッパード
スカーサッダムデーサナ
スカーサンガッササマッギーサマッガーナンタポースコー
スコーブッダハナムッパード
で これ間違ったところで切ってますけど
ブッダハナンと一言間にしなくちゃいけないんですけど
スコーというのは幸福であるという意味なんです
これこそ幸せであると
ブッダハナン ブッダたちのウッパード
生まれること 現れること
いわゆる人が悟ること
この場合は複数形 ブッダといえばブッダ一人なんですけど
で どんな時代でもブッダが現れることこそがもう幸福だよと
現れただけでも スカーサッダムデーサナ
もしそのブッダがサッダム正しい真理を
真理には正しいと言ったらちょっとダサくなりますから
真理を 本当のことを デーサナ教えるならば
ものすごい幸せやと スカーサンガッササマーディ
サンガっていうのはブッダの教えを実践する人々なんですね
ブッダの仲間なんです
これまた仲良くしているんだったら
ブッダの弟子一人がいることでも人間には幸せでしょうし
これまたたくさんいて
これまたすごく仲良くしているんだと
これ上の幸福はないんだと
次に 4行目 サマッガーナンタポースコー
そこで仲良くして タポー修行する
心清らかにするために努力する
それまた人間にとっては幸せやと
だからこれが幸福なんです
これ幸福の定義なんですね
ブッダなんかは現れたこと自体が幸福であると
で それからもうもう 1000年も経ってからとかね
もうもう400年  500年経ってから
誰かさんがね 精神的におかしい人が私こそあれやこれやと言っても
お釈迦様最初に言ってるんだからね
私の現れがあなた方にとっては幸福やというふうなことって
歴史的に調べてもお釈迦様はじめなんです
他ないんです 調べてください
人類の歴史はそれより随分古いんだから
だからそれも何か意味があって言っていることなんです
はい  そこで すべての生命の幸福のため
たった一人の人がこの世で現れるという
エーカプッガロ ビクケレ ロケ ウパジマノ ウパッジャティ バウジャナ ヒタバウジャナ スカハ アッター ヒター
スカハ デヨヌスタナ カタメ エカ プッガロ タターガト ビクキュ アラーン サムマ サムブッドーというふうな
長い文章なんですけど
一行だけ取っていたんですね
で タターガト アラーン サムマ サムブッドー
正覚者であるブッダが現れることだけですよと
人間には幸福というものって
と逆に逆にこの引き算でこれを読むと
他の人はみんな人を騙すんだという意味なんです
それは言わないんです
他誰に聞いてももううまく騙されますよと
ひどい目に遭わされますよ
ということで 堂々ともっと丁寧にお釈迦様は言うんです
やっぱり唯一な人物でいえば
正覚者である如来である
はい 次 はい それからこのではお釈迦様が本当に説法もしました
我々に贈る贈り物とあるのはブッダの教えなんですよ
教え その習慣 残した言葉なんです
では お釈迦様は本当にいろんなことをまとめ
いろんな言葉にまとめますけど
ではブッダが何を言ったんでしょうかと
まとめて言えば 無知を破れ
智慧を開発せよと それ何が悪いんですかね？なんでそれ現代人に合わないんですかね
仏教なんかは今更我々に合わないと言っちゃうと
笑われるのだけ 仏教知ってる人に
この人は私は無知でいいやと言ってることだけだから
バカでアホでマヌケで腰抜けて
まあ我でいいやと これこそ人間ではないかと
というふうないいことでしょう
言ってることなんですよ
お釈迦様が言うのは もうもうもう立ち上がれと
あの専心しなさいと 幸福を目指せと
頑張れと 無知はとんでもないことだよと
無知が並ならぬ苦労を作るんだよと
でも誰も気づいてないでしょ
ここまで歴史上 今日までひどい目に遭ってるのに
人の愚かさで結果で 食べるものも汚染されているし
飲み水も飲めない状態になっているし
吸う空気までもうもう汚染されているし
毎 1 秒単位で子供たちが死んでしまうし
食べるものがなくて たったペニシリンぐらいのもうすごい単純な薬もなくて
子供たちが死んでいるし
この地球に これ人の愚かさでしょうに
無知でしょう 何千何万人殺される
死ぬのは当たり前なんですけど
残酷に殺されてるんですかね
この歴史の中で では 知恵に基づいて人を殺した例一つも出してみてください
あるならば その殺しは正しかったと
人の愚かさで殺したでしょうに
歴史は私は知りません
だが 私は聞いたことはありますね
歴史が現れる前 原始動物で生活していた時は
人間がね 猿からなんとかちょっと進化して
その時ももう他は他の人間見たらその人を殺して食べちゃったんだから
それから人間はもう人間だけ互いに殺し合いということで
なんとか分けをして殺し合う
色が違う では殺しましょうと
花の形が違う やっぱり放っておけない
殺しましょうと 喋る言語が違う
だったら殺しましょうということで
なんでもいいんですよ
相手を殺すんです 政治家というか
権力を握っている人を批判しましたと
では殺すそうと 本当かどうか分かりませんだけど
この戦争映画いろいろものすごいたくさんありますね
これでやる昔見た映画なんですけど
子供たちが学校で勉強しながらふざけて遊んだりする
遊んだりする ヒットラーの写真とか
そこばっかり時間なかったんだから
見て子供はふざけてるんで
それでペンでちょっとこれに
まあもう何て言いますか
いたずらするんですね
ただな 子供の遊びだから
どんなポスターでも子供はちょっとでもマーカーでもあったらヒゲ描いたり眼鏡描いたりするんだからね
それでその写真にちょっといたずらするんですね
それだけのことで このゲスタポというか
このドイツの軍人が教室に入って調べる
いわゆるユダヤ人狩りをする
で これ誰が書いたんですか？と
その子を取っていって殺すんです
という映画の一場面でしたけどね
実際にそれはそういうことがあったかないか
それは私は知ることではありませんし
一応そんなことっていうのはあり得ない話じゃないんです
現代世界でもそういうことは私は結構聞いたことがあります
ちょっとからかっただけで
ちょっと冗談言っただけでも終わったと
人生の そういうふうに不幸に苦しんで怯えて
生活しているのに でも無知はありがたいと
と思うということは何事ですかね
だからお釈迦様がおっしゃった無知を破りなさいよというのは
これはもう永久的に正しい言葉なんですよ
無知が怖いんですよ 知恵を開きなさいよと
知恵さえあればもう何でもうまくいきますよと
ということで これからいくつかゲソ続けていきますけど
で わかりやすく皆様馴染みがあるんだから
できるだけ法華経から引用するんです
で もっとすごいことは他の経典にもありますけど
もう私も一人でびっくりするんです
読んじゃうと だからなかなか紹介することはできないんですよ
できないということは
時間的な関係で 法華経というのはもう誰でも読んでいる
あまりそんなに強烈な文章はないんですからね
すごい淡々と アヤサワマランサモッティタン
マランというこの真ん中の言葉というのは
この錆ですね アヤサアヤアヤスというのは
この鉄 鉄から錆がサモッティタン現れてくるんだ
錆が外から吸着 付着するものじゃないんですよ
鉄から自分の中から錆が現れてくるんだよ
それでたとえたら ためはかどき
それで自分から錆を作って自分を食われていて
むしゃむしゃ蝕んでしまうんだと
いくらすごい鉄といっても
錆が出てきてボロボロになるでしょうに
そのたとえを考えてくださいと
すごいいい鉄の入れ物とか何とかかもしれませんだけど
鉄の中から錆が出てきて
その鉄そのものを破壊してしまいます
エーワンアティドーナチャーリーナン
これアティドーナチャーリーナンというのはすごく意味が難しいんですけど
これがこのまあ 食べるために
生活するために 日常生活するために
もう何でもやるぞと 金さえ入ればいいんじゃないかという生き方
これは在家の場合 出家の場合でも
もうもうもう何かごまかしをしてお布施をもらうとかね
お金さえ入ればいいんじゃないかと
もうお腹いっぱい家族みんなに食べることできれば
これでいいんじゃないですかと
方法はどうでもいいやと言って
もうもう何でもいいんだからやるという
人殺しでも泥棒でもごまかしでも賄賂でも不正でも
騙しでも詐欺でも 偽善行為でも
超能力売りさばくことでも
霊能力者になることでも何でもやる
金に金が入るんだったら
面白いことですよね 超能力者という人々はいくらでも
日本ではだいたい 100人に一人ぐらいいるでしょうに
霊能力者やら超能力者やら
でも何かしてもらうためにはお金
お金をあげなくちゃいけないんですよ
私だったら無料でやってくれって
あんたに超能力あるんだから
自分のものは自分で 日本でいますよ
この 森羅万象を創造した神様という人が
自分が全部やったと でも人のご飯食ってる
もう信じられないほど宮殿みたいなところを作って生活はしてるんですけど
これはまあ日本の財産で一般人のお金を作っているんです
自分でちゃんと奇跡的な宇宙そのものを創造できるのに
生命みんなを操作することできるのに
なんでこの馬鹿にもちょっとした建物ぐらい作ることできないんですかね
それももう世界びっくりするほど
なんとかね まあもうジェイドとかなんとか
そういうもう宝石とか
そういう風な石で作っちゃえば
世界に知られちゃうでしょうね
こんなのはもう人間の技じゃないんだと
いくら調べた地球にはこんな風な地球のすべての宝石を集めてみたっても
これぐらいのことはないんだよと
科学知ってるんだから
それぐらいのこと作っておけば
そうやって超能力で物質現象化するとかね
いう人々もいるんですけど
インドにもいるし 日本人が結構もう飛行機までチャーターして行くし
なんでくだらないものしか作らない
その人だったら だから人間どこまで無知でアホかっていうことなんですよ
だからこの 人間っていうのは
金さえ入るならば何でもする
何でもするという生き方をやってますよ
泥棒でもインチキでも詐欺でも
まあ例の礼失礼してあげることでも
もう祈祷でも何でも何でもいいんだからと
金さえ入ればという そういう生き方をするならば
サーリカンマーに悩んでドゥッカキン
それによってその人々はみんな不幸になるんだと
だから自分がやったことで自分が破壊するんだよと
自分がやったことで自分自身を破壊に陥れるんだと
お釈迦様を出している例えはすごくわかりやすい
鉄を見てください と 鉄から錆が出て鉄を食っちゃう
そのように我々の心の中からもう何でもいいんだから
もうお金さえ入ればという生き方をしちゃうと
自分自身が破壊になるんだと
そこでなんでまだ錆という言葉を使ったんですかというと
これは無知という定義なんです
錆っていうのは無知なんです
だから無知を破りなさいと
でなきゃもう破壊になるんだよと
はい 次 それからどれほどわかりやすく当たり前のことをお釈迦様はおっしゃっているかというと
アサッジャヤマラーマンター
マンターっていうのは学問
勉強 勉強の錆 錆っていうのはアサッジャヤ
復習しないことですね
宿題やらないこと 繰り返してやらないこと
何回何回も繰り返して復習しないと勉強したことにならないんだよと
だから復習しないで一回だけ聞いて
そのまま忘れちゃうと
もうあれは勉強したことにならない
勉強には錆が入るんです
次にアヌッターンマラーガラ
ガラっていうのはサイケ生活
俗世間の生き方 俗世間で生きる人間はアヌッターン
まあ精進努力しないならば
毎日頑張らないならば
それが錆だよと それで壊れちゃいますよ
わかりやすい話でしょ？皆様にしたっても
この条件から脱出 もう免除してるわけじゃないんです
何も努力もしないで ただ家でもう何もしないでいると再起生活できんでしょうに
朝早く起きるわ 徹夜して仕事をするわ
もういろんな苦労しなくてしなくちゃいけないし
頑張らなくちゃいけないんですよ
だからすごく具体的によ
文句文句ぐちゃぐちゃ言わないで
再起で生まれたならば
もう努力するのは当たり前やという
なのに人間どうですかね
神にお祈りしたり 私にはお金くれとか
なんで私は不幸なのかとか
誰かに聞いたり 人に聞くもんじゃないでしょうに
一体なんで私はこんなに不幸ですか？と
知るもんか そんなのは
本人 自分のことだから自分で調べれば
怠けてるんだからなんですよ
適切に頑張らない みんな一攫千金狙ってますよ
それ智慧と思いますか？どんな宗教の話を聞いたっても
全部一攫千金主義で アメリカンドリームとか何とか言ったっても
全部一攫千金思考でしょうに
だから何でもやると お釈迦様はそれにも反対するんだからみんなに嫌われる
金脈に当たったらありがたいのに
なんであんた何言ってるんですか？と
こそこそと頑張りなさいよと
面白くない そんな話はと
私は 18億ぐらい もうもうもう賞金が当たる宝くじ買っちゃいますよと
それで １発で全部幸福だよと
みんなそういうことを信じています
当たった人はいないでしょう
だからそういうところですね
だからお釈迦様に向かって
仏教に向かって何か言えますかと
こそこそと頑張れ あー嫌だ
そんな話はと言うことは
自分が一攫千金一攫もう忘れちゃった
一攫千金主義で生きているんだということですよ
それ考え方は時代恥ずかしいでしょうに
情けないでしょうに だから堂々と胸を張って自分の情けない生き方を見せているだけ
それで再起生活するならば
売った花っていうのは
もう朝早く起きてやることは全部やって
遅くまで頑張ってという生き方はしなくちゃいけない
これも毎日やらなくちゃいけないってこと
やらないと自分の生き方からサビが出てきて
その家が壊れてしまう
もうホームレスになってしまう
あるいはもう自殺してしまう
日本で見える現象っていうのは
家族みんな道連れにして自殺する
車に子供たちみんな放り込んで
それでどこかに崖から落ちゃたり
海に飛び込んだりする
車ごとに そういう生き方って立派ですかね
だったら最初からブッダの話を聞いて
コソコソコソコソとゆっくりゆっくり
まあ家族のために頑張れば
そんなことにはならないでしょうに
頭が悪いだけ 例えば会社から追い出されたと
お金何もないんだと 日本でいっぱい土地があるんですよ
もうもうなんて言いますか
農業する人が手がなくて
もう 80歳のおばあさん
おじいさんにできないんだから
そこらに行ったらもうもうタダでくれるん
貸してくれるんですよ
土地は 別に子供は学校に行かなくたっても死にませんだからね
そこでもう子供と連れて行って
そういう田舎に行って
どこかのおじいさんのおじいさん
ちょうど土地を貸してくださいと
野菜作って何か食べなくちゃあかんと
言うといいよと言ってくれますよ
そこでそういう農業をやっている方々っていうのは
本来立派な人間ですよ
悪いことしてないんだから
そこでその畑で野菜が出るまでは
なんとかなんとか分けてくれます
生きていられますよ それで
なんで車ごとに海に飛び込むんですかね
それって立派な生き方？それ話し出しちゃうと
そんなことしたって そこら辺は小学校はないんではないかとかね
平気で言うんですよ 学校はあったっても
まあ子供はもう ８キロぐらい行かなくちゃいけないんではないかとかね
行って車まるごとに海に飛び込む
これって立派な人間やと言いたいんですかね
そういうことをやりながら
別に人類は必ず学校に行かなくちゃいけないと誰が決めたんですかね
人間の役に立つことをしているのは
この学校に出て 大学出て
すごい資格を取っている人ですかね
その連中 人殺ししかやってないでしょうね
何もできない人々はね
もう平和で幸せで もうキャベツでも作って生活していますよ
だからまあ 別に誰が決めたんですかね
必ずも学校に 教育行かなくちゃいけないとかね
そういうこともないのに
無知は良くないと言ってるだけで
で そういうことだから
田舎生活は嫌だと 都会生活はしたいんだと
何でも便利だと しかし
解雇になったんだから
では家宅でみんなで自殺しましょうという生き方でしょうに
ということだから この
自分の考え方で 行為で自分が破壊してしまう
それで鉄に例えてお釈迦様は教えているんです
サビは鉄の中から現れて
鉄を食いし 蝕んでしまう
壊してしまう 破壊してしまう
そのように我々の生き方
それでサビって何なのことはっきり言ってるんですよ
曖昧じゃないんです 在家の人々には努力しないこと
サビです それだけわかりやすいでしょうに
曖昧な教えでも もう宗教的な教えでも何もないんです
次にマランワンナッサコーサッジャン
ワンナっていうのは この色という字象の意味なんで
ワンナっていうのは健康
美しさ 美容なんです 健康で美しく美容を保ってかっこよく生きたければね
サビがあるんですよ サビはコーサッジャン
怠けること はっきりしています
怠けちゃうと もう体もうすごく体重がいっぱい増えちゃって
病気になって顔色悪くなっちゃって
早く死ぬんですよ そこでスマートで抜群のプロポーションで
もう健康で 生きている間はすごく健康で生きていきたければ
怠けないこと はっきりしていますよ
では それにより完璧な言葉
誰かに言われますかね
みんな言ってるでしょ
毎日 1時間ジョギングすればいいやとかね
野菜食っちゃえ 昨日テレビで野菜食っちゃえばいいやと
なぜならばニューヨーカーが野菜食ってるんだと
だからこれこそや 日本人の神様ってニューヨーカーのバカどもたちが届きたいんですけど
で まあそういうことは言ってるだけでもうくだらん話ですよ
野菜食っちゃえばいいか
魚食べればいいか 毎日何時間もジョギングすればいいかというと
そういう話全部まとめると簡単でしょう
怠けないという一言葉で言えば
怠けない ちゃんと仕事やることはやる
1時間あると まあ 1時間もう何もしないでボケーとしているぞ
これは怠けだからと思っちゃえばもう何かするでしょう
それで何のことなく人生も幸せになるし
健康でもいられるし 体の美しさも保たれますよ
こんなにわかりやすい教えがあるんですかと
ほか世の中で で 次 パマードラーカとマラン
これはお釈迦様が言いたがっている仏教
仏教独特の真理なんです
パマード放逸 いわゆる頭がおかしい状態
常に自分に気づいて 常に目覚め目覚めていない状態
これはちょっと難しいんですけど
ラッカとマラン 自己を守る人にとっては
それがサビですよ 自分を
自分自身を 自分の精神を
自己を完全に守りたいと思うならば
常に気づくというアッパマーダ不放逸実践しなくちゃいけない
皆様散々聞いてるんだから
これは気づきであって
サティであって ヴィパッサナー実践という働きなんです
だからヴィパッサナーという瞑想は 24時間やってくださいと私は言ってるはずですけど
聞いたことがないだけで
それも 24時間自分に気づいて生活しなくちゃ
そうすると自己を守ったことになりますよと
その 4行目 難しいとしても
上の 3行目はわかりやすいでしょうに
当たり前の事実でしょうに
だからお釈迦様と極楽極楽道というか
楽園というのは今すぐ自分で実現できるものなんです
はい 次のスライド マリティアドッチャリカ
マラという言葉とイッティハという言葉を合わせているんです
これは何か出来事をあって喋った芸なんです
イッティハっていうのは
女性に対してはマラ サビって何でしょうかと
ドッチャリカ だらしない性格や
いわゆる不倫すること
すごいかっこ悪いんだと
これでもう壊れてしまいますよ
で この場合はもう男性の場合はものすごく厳しく批判していますけど
いろいろ逃げることもできますけど
女性は遊びたい放題遊んじゃうとそう簡単に逃げられません
体が壊れます 社会ではものすごく
非難されます 自分では立場がないんですよ
女性っていうのはプライド高いんだから
もうかっこよく生活したいでしょう
気分的にも だったらまあ良くない生活をやめなさいと
ということになります
だから そういうことが女性の人生についてはサビであると
次にマチェーランダデトマラン
人に寄付したい 助けてあげたいと
といういいことをしようと思っちゃうと
マチェーラ このケチという気持ちが出てきてやめさせちゃうんです
だから ケチな人はケチのせいで破壊してしまうんですよ
人を助けてあげればものすごく幸せなんですよ
自分の命も守られます
人を助ける人は常に助けられていますから
ケチが働いちゃうとこれできなくなっちゃうんですよ
誰にも助けて誰も助けてあげないで
もう鍵ばっかり増えるんですね
家に そうするとそれで自分が破壊になるんだよと
鍵がある たくさんあると
あの 何といいますか あれは
このセキュリティのカメラやらいろいろたくさんなると
その家は狙われます 人間が作るセキュリティシステムというのはろくなものじゃないんだからね
見ただけで ああ なんだそれってすぐわかりますから
だから狙われますよ そんなことないというならば
泥棒も大したもんとこじゃないんですよ
泥棒で家狙うんだったら
そういう家狙わないと面白くないでしょうに
そこでどこかのアパートに行ったとか
どうせアパートなんかは鍵かけませんし
私も出かける時はもう鍵はかけます
家内だったら鍵開けっぱなしに
ほとんど窓も窓も開けっぱなしで
まあ今から閉めますけど
寒いんだから そんなのに入ったって面白いことなんでもないでしょうに
だったら １メートル間隔でテレビカメラついてる家屋に入った方がいいんです
だから一般のまともな人間だけじゃなくて
泥棒にしたっても情けないんですよ
生き方はもう まあそれはどうせ人間の一般的なことだから
やっぱりこのケチが入ってくると
自分が狭くなって狭くなって
その 自分の生き方がね
もう破壊してしまうんですよ
やがて喉が渇いても水を 1杯でも飲ませてくれる人がなくなっちゃうんですよ
金はいっぱいあるんだけど
水 1杯飲ませてくれる人はない
もう体が壊れちゃうと自分で取って飲めないんだから
年取ってくると美味しいごちそう食べられなくなる
いくらお金があっても片付きも何もできないでしょうに
作ることもできんでしょう
だからケチな人っていうのはそうやってすごく不幸になるということで
それ 3 行目 マラヴェーパーパカダンマアスミンローケパランヒチェ
パパカダンマ 悪いこと
悪行はサビですと アスミンローケパランヒチェ
この世においても あの世においても
悪行はサビですと それでいつでもこの 4 行目になってくると
ブッダは真理 一般的に永久的に変わらない真理に言って終わるんです
1 行目はわかりやすい
もう社会的なことで 女性たちを見てください
すごく品格よく恥を知って生活すると
みんなすごく可愛くて
社会に褒められてくれる
そこをでもどんな人でも出ていらっしゃいというと
男なら誰でもいいやという生活で生活すると
その女性には何の立場もないんですね
それはサビであると わかりやすいでしょうし
そこで人を助けようと思ったら
もうケチが邪魔するんだっていうことはわかりやすい
時にわかる ちょっとわかりにくいかもしれませんだけど
これは永遠不滅の真理なんです
この世であろうとも あの世であろうとも
悪行はサビである だから悪行をやめましょうという話になりますけど
それは言わない お釈迦様は
はい 次 今までの長い話をしたのは
これ言いたいからなんです
たとうマラマラタラン
サビでもよろしい 汚れでもいいんですよ
たとうマラ それよりもまだ足らん
究極なサビ汚れは何なのかと
今まで言ったのはそんなに大したサビではありませんよと
ケチやら不倫することやら
そんな大したサビじゃありませんと
怠けることをやらん でも究極なサビ
究極な汚れがあるんだよと
たとうマラマラタラン
この 2 行目を覚えておいてください
バーニコーテ アヴィッジャーパラマンマラン
究極パラマンというのは究極な
究極な汚れ サビはアヴィッジャー
無明である 無知であると
だから人間はすべての不幸や何らかんでも支配して育てて管理しているのは無明なんですよ
人間が無知を神様だと拝んでいるんです
無知が言う話を聞いて
無知に指導されて 無知に管理されて無知に見守って生きているんだから
まあこういう生き方だよと
これやめなさいと だからこのどんな墨よりも
どんな汚れよりも究極的な極端な汚れが無明
無知です だから比丘たちに言うんですよ
エータンマランパハットワーナ
比丘っていうのは お釈迦様の話を真面目に聞く人々のこと
世間の人間のことじゃないんです
だから エータンマランパハットワーナ
このサビをパハットワーナっていうのはなくして
なくすっていうことですね
ニンマラホーテ 汚れのない状態になりなさいよ
ビッキャオ 比丘たちよ
君らはなりなさいと で
比丘たちに命令するときは比丘たちを振るんですよ
今までなかったでしょ？悪いことするなかれっていうことは
一応そういうことやというだけで
だからこの究極のサビだけなくしましょう
そうすると他のサビ全部なくなりますから
究極的な 極端的な 基本的な汚れを落としちゃうと
他の汚れは全部なくなる
だからこの基本的な汚れを落としなさいよ
あんた方はと比丘たちに言うんです
なぜ比丘たちにだけこうやって区別して言うかというと
比丘たちは真面目にブッダの話を信じて実践しようとする
他の人々は嫌だ 嫌いだ
そんな話はとか言ってるんだから
あまりきつくは言わないんです
元々も期待してないんだからという態度で
しかし 話を理解して出家したならば
はっきりとこれをやりなさい
これをやりなさい これをやってはいけないとか言ってくれる
そこでこのブッダは結局我々に何をおっしゃるかというと
何をおこりもの 贈り物として残したかというと
1 行で言えば 無知を破れ
智慧を開発しましょう
これが悪いんですかね
現代に合わないんですか？現代人が無知でいいんですかね？マインドコントロールされたままでいいんですかね
北朝鮮の国民たちは あの政府が言うことばっかりしか聞かないでしょうに
これでいいと思いますかね
だまされてるかと だから無知はいいわけじゃないんですよ
えーと 次何があるかわからないんですけど
まあ次の次第出してください
で あの 一時間ぐらいやったから
そこから一旦休憩いたします
はい これからあの ちょっと違うテーマに入ってみようと思います
どういうことかというと
テーマはまず結論を言います
釈尊が偉いということ
絶対的に偉い この宇宙で
この存在の中で釈尊に対しては誰にも歯が立ちませんと
対抗できん たとえ世界を創ったという神様でも
釈尊に会ったら尻尾を巻いて逃げると
ということを言いたいんです
で ここら辺で このまあブッダが
如来はすごいということはね
大乗仏教でも言ってますけど
そこら辺は宗教的になって
信仰になって 神秘的になって
拝みばいということで終わってますから
これはお釈迦様が否定している宗教の世界だからね
でも だからといってブッダが偉いということには変わりはありません
大乗仏教でも言っている大日如来やら何やらいろいろいますけど
そのように偉いんだけど
全くそのお釈迦様がそれよりもすごく偉いということ
なんでそんなことを言いますかというと
だからグズグズ言わずに
お釈迦様が言う通りにやってみなさいと
やってみて何か悪いことでもあったら言いなさいよと
なんでこれほど偉いお釈迦様が
これほど知っているお釈迦様がこうしなさいと言っているのに
それを置いておいて こんなどこかで
あの あの けしからな人間を言う話を聞くんですかと
ということなんで 結論は
それでサデーワカスミンローカスミンナッティメーパティプッガルー
神々のもともこの世で私に等しいものはいませんと
堂々と釈尊が言うんです
それにもずっと言ったわけじゃないんです
悟って間もないうち 人にあってちょっと話し合いことになりまして
自己紹介しなくちゃいけなかったんです
そこで自己紹介する羽目になっちゃったんだから
まあ私には等しいものはいませんと
ということだから たとえ神が言っても
そのままゴミ箱に捨てちゃって
ブッダが言ったことは実践するんです
仏教とはね 神様が直々現れて言ったっても聞かない
あっち行けと  それはブッダの方が偉いんです
はい そういうブッダが
神々よりも誰よりもものすごい優れているブッダが言うんです
アパールターテーサンアマタスドアーラ
まず諦めていたんですね
説法はしないんだよと
なのに 一応幸福への福祉への道を開きましたと
道を開通しましたと 耳ある者よ
いわゆる聞きたければ聞けっていうこと
心の扉を開け 目覚めなさいよと
もう話を聞きなさいよと
聞く耳になっただけで人は幸福になります
もう聞く耳のどころか
もうもう自分の恥を大きさに世間でたらしているんだから
私こそもう現代人で 頭が良くで何言ってるんです
それ自体恥なんです やってることを見ると
人間やってることを見ると
ですから この聞いただけでもうすごい素晴らしい人間にはなります
実践するところじゃないんですよ
聞く耳持っただけでもものすごい人格変わるんです
そういう教えなんだから
今まで出した単純な例見たって真面目に考えてみてください
それだけで人生の生き方が変わるでしょうに
神に頼るし 自分の足に自分の足元に頼るんだよということ
だから 人生の照準感を自分の手に渡してくれるんですよ
それじゃなくて明確なマニュアルを出してるんです
だったら誰にも遠慮する必要ないでしょうに
で ヨソートアンソートワンとパモンチャンドサッガー
はい 次に行きます はい
えーと じゃあそこら辺はもう最後に言うことだから
もうちょっと脱線した話をします
元に戻してください と
お釈迦様はなんですごいということはね
お釈迦様はこの一番最初に悟って
すぐ元気な時ね 体力的にすごい爆弾的にお話をしたんだけど
もうどんどんまあ中年ぐらいになってくると
すごく穏やかであんまり爆弾的なことは言えなかったんで
弟子たちもいっぱいいましたから
弟子たちにはっきりした指導することで忙しかった
最初はもう一人も仏教徒はいなかったんだから
言いたい放題のことを言っていたんです
だから この 私もこのお釈迦様のこの最初の生粋態度で喋ってますけど
本当に真剣に仏教は真面目にやっている人々の間ではそういう話
態度はないんですよ すごくニコニコとお出やかで
ああ そうですね この場合はこういうことではないんでしょうかという風に態度変わるんですよ
で お釈迦様は何者かと知るためには
お釈迦様に攻撃かけないとダメなんです
でないと全然自分のことは言わないんです
全くに もし誰かあんた何者か
誰があんたのことを信じるかって
なんかそうやって攻撃かけると
お釈迦様は何者かと見せるんです
そこで ヴェーサーリという国で
あるスナッカートという名前の人がヴェーサーリー人で
リッチョイという結構お釈迦様を信頼していた民族なんです
ヴェーサーリー国っていうのはほとんど仏教徒でしたからね
リッチョイという人々はリッチョイ族というかね
リッチョイという民族
このリッチョイの中の一人
スナッカートです 名前は
出家して 還俗したんですよ
出家やめたんです これ還俗するってなかなかブッダの時代ではそんなあったわけじゃないんで
一旦出家したらもうきちんと悟り開くんだから
この人はなんかちょっとお釈迦様と喧嘩になっちゃって還俗したんです
で 還俗したところで もう腹が立って出家還俗したんだから
もう仏教は嫌やと お釈迦様に悪口を言うんです
どういう悪口かというと
ナッティサマナッサゴータマッサウッタリマヌッサダンマアラマリアニャーナダッサナヴィセーソ
このゴータマシャモンゴータマにウッタリマヌッサダマ
人間を超えている 人間のレベル超越している知恵なんかありません
聖なる知恵なんか何もない
タッカパリヤータン サマナゴータモ ダンマン デーセティ
ただ論理的に喋ってるね
タッカっていうのは論理
すごい見事な論理的に喋ってるんだよと
しかし 超越した智慧はないんだと
ヴィーマンサーヌチャリタン
まあ知識で考えて考えて
この学者の講義みたいな感じで
学者の講義をやっているような感じで
知識的に考えて喋ってるんだと
えーと サヤンパティバーナ
その時その時のひらめきで喋るんだよと
しかし 言ってる通りにやればね
ヤッサチャ カッサアッターイ ダンモーデーシと
でも 言ってるようにやってみれば
まあそれはそのなりになりますよと
という風に批判するんですね
ブッダはただ何もわかってない
ただ理屈で喋ってるだけで
でもやる側は何かありますか？何かありますか
え？いや しかし まあやってみたらね
まあなかなかその通りになるんだよと
いう風に批判するんですね
これはこの自分を褒めてお釈迦様を貶すためにそう言ってるんです
お釈迦様は全然もう超越した智慧なんか何もない
ただ理屈で喋ってるだけ
やってみたらなかなか結果がありますよというのは
これ自分のことなんです
というどういうことがでないと
お前 あんた本当にやってもないでしょ
ブッダの教え だからやってやりもしないでね
ブッダに悪口言うなとみんなから言われるでしょうに
だから自分の立場を守るために
このこの 一行目を入れるんです
だから一応出家していくらか
もうもうそれなりにあのもうなんとか修行したんだから
そこの分は結果があるんです
その人に しかし お釈迦様といろいろちょっとからくりがあって
もうもうギクシャクすることがあって
あのもう出て行っちゃったんです
で サーリプッタ尊者もこの話はあちこち言いふらしちゃいますから
この人は 減速する人っていうのはそんなにいるわけじゃないし
お釈迦様の時代で だから一人は減速したと言ったらみんなびっくりするんですよ
特に邪教の人々は 他の宗教の人々はなんで何かありますか？とかね
これ聞きたいでしょ？どこら辺気に入らなかったんでしょうかとか
だからそれだけで で 中の状況ね
うちの状況を知りたくて
で 有名になったんですよ
そこでサーリプッタ尊者がその話を耳に入ってお釈迦様に報告する
報告したら これ15ページぐらい続けてる経ですよ
はい でお釈迦様はこう言うんですね
コードの閉鎖サーリプッタスナッカットモググリス
そのスナッカッタがね
あいつはただ怒っているんだと
私は 別に真面目なこと言ってるわけじゃなくて
ただ怒ってなんかゴチャゴチャ言ってるだけやと
コーダーチパナエーサーワーチャーバーシタ
彼の批判っていうのはあてにするもんじゃない
ただ怒って言ってることですよと
でないと批判もちゃんとあてにしますよ
お釈迦様は ただ怒っていること
あんた怒ってるだけでしょと終わっちゃうんです
そこで怒っているんだったらバカやと
アワーナンバーシッサーミーティ
私を非難しよう 侮辱しようと思って
この人はワンナメーイエバハーサティ
結局私を賞賛しているんだと
だってバカだから怒っていて
ブッダは侮辱してやろうではないかと言ってブッダを賞賛しているんだと
あんたアホじゃないかと
なぜならば 私が言っていること
教えていることは実践すると見事にその通りになるんだよということこそ
私に対する賞賛ですよと
だって世の中でどんな宗教もそれはできないんだから
やってみなさい  100%この通りになりますよということは
世界で誰も言わないんだから
だからそれがブッダの特色で
仏教の特色で 実践すれば結果はもう確率性は100%です
だからそれ言っちゃうんだ
それが私に対して何よりも賞賛だよと
でもしかし 本人は怒って侮辱しているつもりですと
ということで お釈迦様は相手にしないんです
しかし ブッダに個人的にブッダをけなしているんだから
ブッダ自身には超越した智慧がないんだと
人間の乗り越えた智慧がないんだというところは
まあブッダ自身に対する個人的な侮辱だからね
そういうことを言われるとお釈迦様は自分のことを言うんです
それからもう長い長い経典なんですけど
まあこれぐらいいっぱいあります
パーリ語だから これ日本語訳するともう分厚いテキストになります
自分のことを説明するんです
一番簡単なことはね あの愚か者が私はこのイティピソバガワーアラハンというお釈迦様の九つの特色がありますね
これは仏教であることは人は誰でも覚えているんです
皆さんはテキストはもしかするとたまたま目に触れたことがあると思います
イティピソバガワーという
そこで意味が書いているんです
意味を読んでみてください
九つの特色があります
お釈迦様に 阿羅漢であって
正覚者であって 道徳と智慧が完成してあって
いろいろあります 世間
世間は知っている人であってとかね
人を調教するためには
この上のものはいないとかね
その九つ これは全然わかっていないんだと
私はどれほど能力があるかというと
それはイティピソという九つっていうのは
ただお釈迦様に付き合っただけでわかるんですよ
お釈迦様っていうのはすごい人格だと
みるみるうちに人々を育てていくんだから
ちょっと二 三分で  10 分でもうもう相手をきちんと育ててみせる
だからそれを見ると誰でもびっくりしますよ
この邪教の他の宗教の人々でも
これだけはもう頭上げられませんと
ブッダに会ったらもう終わりやと
もうその人は顔を見たら仏教徒になっちゃいますよと
だから仏教嫌いだったら
せいぜいブッダに会わないことやと
いくら大胆な哲学者で世界に旗を立てていても
もう顔合わせたらあんた終わりやと
それで何のことなくその教えを信じるようになっちゃいます
だから お釈迦様のそういう人格的なところはよく知られていたのに
スナッカッタがそれさえもわからなかったと
次に それから一般人にわからないブッダの能力を言うんです
スナッカッタこれもわからなかった
私はあらゆる人数を持っていること
その能力があることはわからなかったと
私は一人でいて二人になれる
四人にもなれる 10人にもなれる
いっぺんに いわゆる自分の形を復元できる
いくらでも それえ 複製
複製できる お釈迦様はまあ実際は一人なんですけど
全く同じ体で形を作ろうと思ったらすぐ作れます
で まあそれぐらいものすごい修行すると
普通の人にもできないわけないんだけど
お釈迦様もっと能力あるんですよ
喋らせるんです この複製した幻想にも
同じことでもないんで
別なことでも喋らせるんです
もし対話するための仏教は全部対話だから
だから質問がないと仏教っていうのは説法はできないんです
これいつでも私は言うんだから
皆様は絶対質問だけはしてやるないぞという風にもう口を固くしていますからね
そうすれば説法するんだからと
これはすごい仏教に対してすごいもう勝てない攻撃なんですよ
そうしちゃうともう勝てなくなるんです
人間の知識は知れたもんだから
こちらで勝手には喋れないんですよ
質問するとそちらに合わせますからわかるようになります
とにかく置いておいて
例えば議論する相手がなければ
同じブッダを作ってでもそちらと議論することもできます
それはブッダ以外は誰もできない
なぜならば この複製するシステムありますからね
どんなものにも科学的な法則がありますから
その科学的な法則で考えると
喋れ 喋らせる 喋られることは無理です
別なこと お釈迦様の弟子一人がいて
そうやって複製技術を技を身につけたんですよ
身についてもうたくさん自分同じ形を複製して見せたんだけど
喋ろうと思っちゃうと同じことをみんな喋るんです
複製品だから 別な別々なことを喋らせることはできないんです
これがお釈迦様だけの能力でそれできる
それさえもそれだけじゃない
お釈迦様はね この どこでも自由に動ける
横であろうが縦であろうが
人間というのは地面の上でしか動けないでしょうに
お釈迦様は横縦もうもう多次元的に体を動かすことはできると
壁があったっても何のことなく通ってしまう
山があってもすぐ通ってみせるという
土の中に潜ってみせる
水の上で歩いてみせる
そんなの朝飯前でいつでもいつでもできると
この水の上に歩くとかね
そんなのはね まあいろいろ他の宗教でもやらそうなこと言ってますけど
仏教にとっては当たり前のごく普通の日常茶飯事のことです
お釈迦様どうやってインドあれほど毎日歩いていたんですかね
川があったり 洪水があったり
困ったという一言はないですよ
どこでも いきなりすごい長距離を走っている
歩いているでしょうに
どうやって歩くかというと
ここで峠で山が通ってトンネル掘っていくんです
瞬時に  そんなのはごく普通で
でもデモンストレーションはしないんです
でも お釈迦様のところで出家して
お釈迦様と一緒に歩く場合は
もうそっちを毎日のようにいろいろ
あまりにも毎日のことでだから
誰も奇跡や不思議やと言ったことも言わない
それが仇になっちゃって
これは仏教徒のインチキだと
奇跡はイエス様にのみあるものだと西洋の仏教学者たちが言うんです
で こちらでもこれこそが
すごいやと書いてあった方が良かったのに
だからイエス様がある日なんか海に流されちゃったことで
それでやっと救いが救われましたけど
弟子たちにボートに で
これでびっくりするんです
まあそれはどちらかどちらかわかりませんだけど
これもわからなかったと
この人これぐらい能力あるっていうことを
それからお釈迦様の力っていうのは
この威力というか パワーっていうのはどこまででもあるんだよと
それを象徴的に太陽とか月とか
手を伸ばして触ってみせることができるんだと
そこでお釈迦様のこの精神的な力のことを言うんです
だからヤーはブラフマローカ
この世界創造者といわれる梵天のところまで私の存在が響いているんだよと
だからどこへ行ってもものすごい迫力なんです
だからそんなことはわからなかったと
これぐらい人相 超能力
いろんな超能力っていうものはね
あったのに それだけじゃないと
なぜ私は自分の耳であらゆる音を聞いてますよと
人間のこと 言葉を聞いたければ
どこにいてもすぐ聞こえますよ
神々の話を聞きたければ
どこでもすぐ 耳の調整を合わせるだけ
調整した途端 そこの言葉は全部聞こえる
だから全く人間には考えられない
この超越した この聴覚というか
天耳というんですけど
その神通があって すぐ目の前でいて立って聞いているような感じで聞くことはできますと
しかし この人はそれもわからなかったと
それからお釈迦様が人々の心っていうのは見事に読み取っているんだ
私は人の心っていうのはいたも簡単に読み取っているんだと
自分の心 心は汚れているか
汚れていないか 怒っているか
怒っていないか 混乱しているか
もう何から何まで人の心の働きっていうのは明確に
他人の心 私は自分の心を知っていますよと
成長している人とか成長していない人とか
誤解している人とか ちゃんと悟っている人とか
あるいは悟り悟っているんだと勘違いしている人とかとか
心が見事に釈迦さんに読み取れるんだからこそ
昔の人々は釈迦さんの言うことはもう何も逆らう
反対することなく聞くんです
だからよくあるんだよ
お釈迦様はあなたこの瞑想しなさいと言ったら
でも私はこれが好きですよというと終わりです
わがままを出しちゃう
だから出家は絶対わがままを出さないんです
釈迦さんがまあ先生が言ったならば
先生に言われたんですけど
その瞑想はちょっと自分の性に合わないということもありえますよ
そこでお釈迦様が君はこういう瞑想しなさいと言うと
何もことなく はい わかりましたとやるしかないんです
なぜならば 心は明確に読み取ってから出す結果なんです
すまなかったもいろいろ超能力好きで
で そういうことを教えてくださいと
お釈迦様はあんたいい加減やめなさいと言われたんです
一部は成功したんですよ
瞑想して彼にもいろんなものが見えるようになっちゃったんです
見えるんだけど聞こえない
お釈迦さんはいろいろ瞑想すると見えたりはしますけど
聞こえません 教えてちょうだい
あんたやめなさい それはと言ったところで怒ったんです
自分と同じくなるのを嫌がっているんだと
ブッダ自分と能力が同じになるのはと
お釈迦様の能力にはもう誰一人近づることできないのに
この馬鹿がわからなかったんです
普通だったら やっぱり何か訳があるでしょう
釈迦さんに断られたら
あれはもうやめるものだと潔く
というと 素直ではなかったんです
そういうことで お釈迦様は人の心は見事に読む
でも この人にはそれがわからなかったと
だから私に超越した能力がないんだと智慧がないんだと言うんだけど
こういうふうに人間に想像できない
とてつもない能力を持ってるんだよと
堂々と発表するんです
釈迦様は嘘をつかないんですよ
釈迦さんの家が なんで釈迦族であることをはっきりしますかというと
この釈迦族という民族が殺されても嘘は言わないというのが
その民族の一つ決まりなんです
誰でも釈迦族の人であるならば
だから一般的な人であっても
釈迦の釈迦族の人だから嘘は言わない
すごい態度だから 人騙しはしない
これでブッダになって嘘を言ったっていうことはありえないでしょうに
何のために言うんですかね
私にはいろいろ超一流の力あるんだよと
そんなことなくたって
お釈迦様はもう天才的な知識能力を持っているんだから
ただ普通に喋っただけでみんな圧倒されるでしょうに
だからあったんだから
ちゃんと言っていること
それでもお釈迦様の虫が収まりません
自分の超能力って本当のところ言っただけでも
さらに言うんです 私には私にだけある
誰にもないあらゆる力があるんだよと
これ他の人にもあるかもしれませんだけど
この完成していないんだと
私ほどいわゆる頂点に持っていってないんだと
そこそこなんとかかもしれませんですけど
そこでお釈迦様の との十ですから
全ての生命を乗り越えているんだと
この十種類の能力で だから自信満々で
アーサバンターナンパティジャーナ
大勝利者と 私には右に出るものはないんだと
私の記録は絶対誰にも破れませんと
というふうに私は堂々と言ってますよと
シーハナダネになって
獅子子 何でしたっけ？獅子宮
もうそのようにものすごく堂々と私は言ってますよと
人間であろうが 神々であろうが
梵天であろうが どこでも言いますよ
ブラフマチャッカムパワッテーディという言葉があります
それは特別に解釈しなくちゃいけないんですよ
ダンマチャッカ 法輪という言葉がありますね
それからブラフマチャッカということもあります
ブラフマといえば煩悩ですけどね
法輪でも梵輪でもおなじみなんです
このなんで法輪といえば
今日は考え出した用語なんですけど
これは生命の憲法なんです
お釈迦様はこの初転法輪経で何を教えるかというと
生きるものが生きとし生けるものの絶対的な憲法
幸福になりたければ実践するべき憲法
これはもう誰に一旦憲法を定めたら
まあ誰にも何することもできないんだと
だからダンマチャッカという言葉を使うんです
だからチャッカの意味は憲法なんです
で ブラフマチャッカとも言うんです
ダンマチャッカといえば
ダンマは法でしょうし
ブラフマといえばこの神に使う言葉だから
やっぱりこれは絶対的な憲法っていう意味なんです
だから自分がこの十種類の能力があるんだから
すべての生命に対する憲法を定めているんだと
いわゆる絶対的な存在っていう意味なんです
決めるのは私しか決める人はいませんということ
一番目の能力は何なのかというと
ターナンチャターナトアッターナンチャアッターナトヤタハブータンパジャーナ
これがちょっと注釈書を調べるのを忘れちゃったんではなくて
時間はなかったんです
全部この朝 10時から作り出しましたから
昨日ちょっと体の調子がすごく悪くて
いわゆるこのターナターナっていうのは
このすごいもの もうまあ日本語にすればわかるかもしれませんだけど
意味が難しいんだから
この 例えば何でもやっただけでいいわけじゃないんですよ
世の中のことっていうのは
どんなものでも行うべき
時間というものをね やってはいけない時
やるべき時といういつでもあるんですよ
いかなるものについてあっても
だから 例えば人は修行するべきなんですよ
でなきゃ心は汚くて地獄の不幸になるんですよ
だからといって やむを得ずにいつでもというわけじゃないんですよ
ちょうど今という時期があるんです
いくら修行だといっても
今はあんたやめた方がいいよと
というこの時期っていうものがあるんです
だからそこは条件なんですね
条件を見て判断しなくちゃいけない
これが普通の人には全くわからないんですね
お釈迦様にとってはもう手に取っているように
今はこういうことをやる時期ですと
今はこれをやる時期ですと
だから仏教徒っていうのは
昔からブッダ言うことには絶対いかなる場合でも逆らわない
もし人がお釈迦様 私はこれから瞑想修行しますからと言ったら
お釈迦様はあんたね ご飯食べなさいと言ったならば
もう一言も言わないで
はい わかりましたと言ってご飯食べますよね
なぜならば これブッダしか知らないんですよ
この条件 時期 そういうことで
まあ我々にはできませんよ
私たちやってみるしかわからないではないかというふうな感じなんですけど
お釈迦様 やってみる 見なきゃわからないという言葉はブッダにはないんです
今これやりなさいと こういう結果になると
今これやりなさいと このターナターナとの人の生命に対して
このその条件に合わせて何をするべきかとするという
そこをわかる能力っていうのはブッダにしかないんだと
だからお釈迦様はすごい大胆に喋ってるんです
全然怖いっていう感じもあるっきりない
それから一番すごいことっていうのは
人々の 業に過ぎて 業に過ぎて
ものすごく知っている
これもその場合はだいたいお釈迦様は過去
将来のことをあまり知るとは言わないんですけど
この場合はアティーターナガタパッチュパンナーナ
人の過去現在 将来 三世にわたって業の働きを知ってますよと
それもただ単じゃないんです
厳密に明確に知ってますよ
それで業論っていうのは
我々にお釈迦様が教えられているんだから
業論 法則は我々にもわかりますよ
一番誰にも知ることできないのは
この具体的にどんな業でどういう結果得られているというところなんです
これだけは絶対考えてもいけないんだと
人間は 人間にはわからないんだと
で 一般的に 例えば殺生したら病弱になる
短命になる それぐらいで十分だと
しかし ある短命な人がいる
その人の場合 お釈迦様は
この人は過去生で こういう過去生で
こんな状態になっていた時は
こういう日でこういうことをしました
この業の結果だよというふうに明確に言うんです
これは地球の砂の中で
ある特定の砂一つ選ぶぐらいのものなんです
だから人間にはできない
こんなのにお釈迦様というのは見事にそれは当たるんです
だからお釈迦様の業を知る能力っていうのは
もう想像を絶する もう検索能力を持ってるコンピューターみたいんです
ただデータがインプットした瞬間でもうこれだという結果が出る
これも一つ だから人類にはお釈迦様は生命の憲法を定めているんだと
それからお釈迦様はサッバッタガーミニパティパダっていうことを知ってるんだと
サッバッタガーミニパティパダっていうのは
まあ現代風に言えば望みを叶う方法なんですけど
でも意味がちょっと違うんです
どこで生まれ変わりたいと思うならば
そのその特定の場所に生まれ変わるためにどうすればいいかと
これは人間はもうすごい大雑把で
死んでから天国に行きたいなとかね
それだけ大雑把でしょ
ブッダはそうじゃないんです
天国と言ったっても ものすごい多数多次元
複数でしょうし 梵天と言ったってものすごい多数多次元
複数にあるし 生命もそうやってもうものすごいたくさんいるんです
それある特定の場所を狙っちゃうと
そちらに行くためにどうすればいいかということ
それ知っています 例えば人間で生まれ人間に生まれたいといえば
人間でどこかで生まれるだけでしょ
そうではなくて 人間にも生まれたいし
しかしこういう風な職業できる人間にもなりたいと決めちゃうと
どんなことをすればいいかという
すごい具体的に人の道を知っているんです
それから お釈迦様は世界は知っている
宇宙は知っている アネーカダートゥ
ナーナーダートゥローカンヤターブータンパジャーナ
この宇宙空間 無数に複数にもうあるでしょうね
一箇所では一箇所でお釈迦様教えてあるんです
宇宙ってこういう風にできているんだよと
いわゆるこの星団やらいろいろ絡み合って
また太陽は現れたり消えたり
まあごちゃごちゃという世界は
まあただ自分の目で見ているような感じでおっしゃった時ところもあります
その宇宙空間にあるあらゆる太陽系やら星団
星団やら そういうのは私はありのまま知っているんだと見ているんだ
だから信じられないほどの望遠鏡的な能力を持っていたということなんです
これはもう信じられません
人間には これはブッダにしかついてない能力なんです
ハブル望遠鏡とかね 宇宙望遠鏡とかね
それでもろくなものは映らないでしょう
お釈迦様はこういう位置で
こういうくらいのこういう大きさの
こういうことを世界あるんだよとかね
何のことなく言える でも同時に言ってないんです
言ったっても 誰がわかるんですかね
だからだからこういうことを知ってるんだよということだけは置いておいているんです
それでこの無限大の宇宙を知ってるでしょ
同時に無限大の生命も知ってるんだと
過去生命がどんな性格を持っているかと
この向き不向き  どんな生命も
あ この人はこういう風な向きがある
こういう風は これは不向きだと
この人々のこの気持ちの世界
明確に知ってるんだと
いわゆるその生命がどういう訓練を受けて
どういう風な心を育てていて
今は何に向いているかということはよくわかります
それから人々の能力の基本というんですね
能力 能力の上下はちゃんと知ってますよ
見たらこの人はここら辺で能力あるんだけど
ここら辺で能力は減っている
だから見事に知ってるんだから
人を育てるということを全くこの人は知恵はあるんだけど
集中力はなし じゃあこれはこうやって育てるんだと
それで向き不向き知らないとまた指導できんでしょ
だから向き不向きも知っている
それから お釈迦様は世の中に宗教
修行というものあるならば
それは一切知り尽くしているんだと
世の中には修行というもの
どんな瞑想をしたらどういう精神的な境地に至れるか
すべて知り尽くしているんだと
それで その精神的な状況は何なのか
このこのある宗教のある修行をすれば
心はどこまで綺麗になるんでしょうかと
どこで残るんでしょうかと
それは知ってますよと
それからその禅定状態
神秘体験なんぞやから
そういう人がと言っているものからものの短所長所を全部知ってるんだよと
そういうものから切り離せるために心を何するべきかと
そこまで知ってますよ
だから宗教経験というものは
もう全部知り尽くしてるんだよと
瞑想のことですね  それから釈尊が自分の過去生は知りたい放題知ってるんだと
過去生といえば無限ですから
無限の過去というのはいくらでも知りたい放題知ってる
自分の方 それでは終わらない
それで過去を知ることも中途半端じゃないんですよ
明確に名前 寿命 場所も何から何まで
いくらの過去でもお釈迦様は知りたい放題知られますよと
それで終わらない それから自分の能力で他の生命のこと
何やってるんでしょうかと
どこでこの人死んだらどこに生まれ変われるんですかと
今こちらに生まれ変わっているのはどこで生まれるんですけど
この先にどこにいたんですかと
これさ もう全部明確に知ってるんだと
こう言いながらと自慢だけじゃないんですよ
どのように知ってるかという
これもちゃんとあります
お釈迦様はどうやってこういう検査しますかと
この検査する方法も全部書いてます
この検査する場合は何かの単語
言葉必要でしょ インプットするために
そういうのがザーッとあるんです
これこれすると淡々とそのデータが出てくると
で 御論を語ったのは そうやってあらゆる生命を見てからね
あの人はすごく立派な格好はいいなと
美しくて生きている 過去生どこにいたんですか？と
この性格はどうやっていたものですかと
なんで美しい身体になったんでしょうかと
それは心はどこで心はこの体を作ったんですかと
これがこの心はこの体を作ったと
その心は過去で こういう行為の結果だよと
ということを知ってるんだから
見事に御語というのはお釈迦様に語られます
あるいはある人が頭がすごい鋭い
しかし身体はもうあまり良くないというか
美しくはない で この人にも心がこれほど鋭く働いている
しかし ごちゃごちゃの身体なんですと
では その基本的な心でなぜそうなったんでしょうかと
なんでこんな体と心が作ったんでしょうかと
これが原因だと この心はもう過去でなんとかなんとか
そういうところで こういう行為の結果だよとはっきりするんです
それは知ってるんですね
一応 そこでお釈迦様が心にあるすべての
煩悩をなくして 汚れをなくして
一つも残らず完全に心をきれいにして解脱を得ているんだと
知り尽くす 知り得るものはすべて知り尽くしているんだと
だから堂々と人類の中で
生命の中で何の遠慮もなく喋ってるんだと
で 人類にだから憲法を定めているんだと
だからお釈迦様定めるんです
これが君たちの生きる憲法やということ
この種種類の能力はあるんだからなんです
そこで自分も言いました
お釈迦様は特別な能力
で こういう ぐらい能力ある私に対して
何も力がないんだ もうただ理屈で喋ってるんではないかと言うと
それは地獄に落ちるんだな
その気持ち捨てない限り
地獄に落ちるんだと これでお釈迦様は虫が収まりませんね
今はもうたくさん言ったでしょうに
まあこれぐらいでやめればっていう
わかりました わかりましたと
お釈迦様はそれでも止まりません
また また私に 4つありますよと
あの10からまた これで私はもうどんな生命の中でもウェーサーラという
いわゆる一人前プロやと
見切れてるものはないんだと私は言ってますよ
これが一番大事なこと
私はサンマーサンブッダ正学者である
いわゆる正しくすべてのものを悟ったと私はみんなの前で
表現発表しています 公言しています
なのに シャモンであろうが
バラモンであろうが 神であろうが
マーラであろうが 梵天であろうが
この存在の中で 一人もいませんよと
私に対して いわゆるなんて言いますか
クレームつける人は 私は完全に一切悟っているんだという場合は
これも公言していると
ちょっと待ってよと言う人はいませんよ
だから人間であろうが
ボラモン人であろうが
ブラモン人であろうが
神であろうが 梵天であろうがいませんよ
一人も いわゆる私に対してこの訴え
違うんではないかということはありませんと
どういう風に訴えるかというと
あんた悟ってるんだけど
これ知らないでしょ？ということはできないと
あんた悟ってるんだと言ってるのはいいんだけど
でもあんた知らないこと一つありますよと
あるならば出てこいという態度ですよ
お釈迦様は だからお釈迦様が悟りというのを理解するという意味でとってます
理解していない わかってないものは何かあるんだったら言ってみなさいよと
要は堂々たることなんです
そこで綺麗に直せば 私は一切の汚れを取り払ったと
全滅したんだと 滅尽しましたと言ってますよ
みんなの前で 煩悩っていうのはもう知る人すらいないんだよ
そう言ってるのに 私はみんなの前で堂々と一人もないんだぞ
この生命の中で 神々であろうが
梵天であろうが 人間であろうが
一人も出てこないんだよと
私に対して攻撃かかる人は
でも釈尊が言ってるのはありがたいんだけど
こういうものあるんじゃないの？とか
何か一つ見せられますかと
できんとというすごい態度なの
いわゆるもうブッダが今
今何か煩悩あるんだよと
まだまだあるんだよということはできませんと
そういう そういう攻撃は
なのに日本の学者はやってます
お釈迦様 煩悩 日本の学者
堂々と言うんで 煩悩をなくすということはありえませんと
なぜならば 煩悩っていうのは生きるものの本能であると
したがってブッダは煩悩を管理したんであって
なくしたわけじゃないと
それで学者だと思ってるんですね
ブッダな状況を研究したければ
この経典の中身から研究するんですよ
あなた何考えてるのか関係ないでしょうに
俺がそう思ってるんだから事実だという話でしょ
これで学者ですよ 煩悩っていうのはなくせないと思ったらそのバカでしょうに
腰抜けで何も努力したこともないし
感情に溺れて引っ張られて生活していて
金のためにやってる研究でしょ
金と名誉のために それ自体煩悩でしょう
それで俺がそう思ってるのが正しいよと堂々と言うんですよ
そこで世界中みんな学者の論文がと言っているもんだから
どうぞ読んでください
だからお釈迦様に煩悩があるかないかというならば
それを経典の中から証明しなくちゃいけない
だからその学者はこのところにさえ都合が悪いんだから読まないんです
こちらはお釈迦様がもうあまりにも大胆に
人間は絶対やらない大胆さでしょ
こんな自慢 人間はしませんよ
いくらなんだろう いくら頭がおかしいと言っても
それをお釈迦様が言うんで
これは誰にもできん自慢だよと
だから私は煩悩をなくせましたと言います
しかし 私にはくらいちょびっとでも煩悩あると訴える人っていうのは
梵天から人間まで誰にもできません
いません そこで 3番目のお釈迦様の極端な自慢
私はこういうことはしない方がいいよ
したらひどい目に遭いますよ
不幸になりますよという
こういうことをしなさいよと
すると幸福になりますよと私は言ってますよと
できるなら逆らってみなさい
私が言ったことは全くもその通りですと
だからブッダがやるなかれ
不幸になると言ったならば
いえ それでもやり方次第だよとは言えませんね
我々よく言うでしょ 一般的には
やっぱりやっぱり 例えば金がよく
まあそれはやり方次第だと
適当に使えば最高の幸せだというふうなのが俗人の考え方で
ブッダは違うんです ブッダがこれが不幸になると言ったことは
やり方次第で変わるわけじゃないんです
これが幸福になる道と言ったら
これはもう絶対的なんです
だからブッダが言うんで
私に誰にもチャレンジできませんよと
誰にも訴えてこないんだと
私が言ったことは 例えば嘘をつくなよと
嘘をつくと不幸になりますよと
お釈迦様は嘘をつくなということで無条件でしょ
殺生するなかれっていうことは無条件のでしょ
まあ殺されかけている頃
殺されかける場合は やっぱりその場合は罪がないと私たちは言うんだけど
お釈迦様はそう言ってないんです
だからそれが正しいんですよ
だからここで言うのは
自分がやるなかれ やりなさいということはそうでないと言えません
4番目 私はすべての苦しみをなくすために
一切の苦を乗り越えるために説法しているんだと
いわゆる究極な幸福のため
生半可の幸せのためじゃないんです
これで私の教え実践して悟りっこはないと言えるならば言ってみなさいと
これぐらい大胆な言葉というのはありますかね
お釈迦様のこの大胆な自慢
私はすべての苦しみをなくすために
究極な幸福を得られるためにこの修行をしているんだよと
悟れないというならば言ってみなさいよと
これでは悟れませんよと言える人間
神々 梵天もいません だから私はすごい安心で安全で安穏で大胆できているんだと
何の心配もなく 世の中
だからお釈迦様が生命に献身を固めているのです
これでお釈迦様の虫が収めたと思いますかね
もう 16 ページぐらいです
ここら辺で我々はいい加減にやめましょう
それから各生命のことを説明していくんですよ
お釈迦様 誰に会ったことがありますかと
私は梵天にももうとっちらって喋ることありますよ
向こうは怯えるんでって
私は全然もう緊張するということを思ったこともないんだよという感じでいろいろあって
それから生命というのはどのように誕生するかと
これ自慢で言ってるんですよ
全部知ってますよ いかなる生命であろうとも
誕生する場合はこんな方法やとよしかないんだよと
で 生命が生まれ変わったり
輪廻転生するとどういう風になりますかと
これこれしかないんだよ
どこ行ったっても いわゆる六道のこと
こちらは五道としているんです
日本では一般的に輪廻六道
輪廻六道と暗記で言うんですけど
六道は何かはあんまり気にしないし
だいたいこっちはこの教典では五道なんです
それから この各生命の運命はお釈迦様はどれほど確かに言えますかということをずっと説明しているんです
そこで世の中の修行にすべて私は試してみてない
修行っていうのは絶対ないんだと
それで世の中で苦行はいいやとありがたいと言ってるんですけど
私ほど苦行した人はいませんよと
それで私は苦行しているんだと
そこでホウマというものがありますね
火を焚いて護摩法じゃない
法魔って何ですか？と
護摩を焚くとかね ヒンドゥー教で護摩を焚いたら悟りますよとではなくて
梵天に行きなさいと言ってるし
まあ仏教でもやってますけどね
私ほど この火の工事やった人は死にませんと
だからなんでそういうことを今だからいい加減私はやめなさいと言ったらやめなさいという意味なんですよ
そこでもお釈迦様は能力ずっと言ってます
えーと 一番最後のところで言いましょうか
そこでこのバラモン人たちはこんなことを言いますよと
人間というのは 若い時は髪の毛が黒い時は頭がすごくいいんだよと
でも髪の毛白くなって年取ってくるとボケますよと言ってるでしょうと
しかし 比丘たちよ バラモン人のみんな普通でしょ
それ常識でしょ 若い時はみんな頭がいいんだけど
歳 歳 歳になってきて 体ボロボロになってもほとんどボケてるんだと言いますけど
お釈迦様こう言うんです
サーリプッタ 私は今歳ですよと
かなりボロボロですよと
体は ものすごく老いてますよと
すごくお釈迦様の体はね
すごくボロボロでしたから
最後は でも 人の弟子たちが歳ぐらいの寿命のある弟子たちが
人いっぺんに私に質問するとします
たやす質問するとします
それで私は答えますよと
しかし トイレに行ったりとかね
ちょっと疲れ ちょっとお休みになるとか
そういう時間は置いておいて
普通活動する時間でずっと絶えず質問する人たちに私は答えますよと
しかし 百年私は答えて説法しても
私に言いたいことっていうのはそれでも山ほどあるんであって
言ったことは少ないんだよと
それでボケたと言えるのかという態度なんです
それで私は寝たきりになって
君たちは私を担いで私の面倒を見ても
私のパンニャーレイヤーって智慧の働きっていうのはまるっきり衰えること知りませんよと
いつでも質問したら答えられますよ
こんなもんで その経典が終わるんですよ
それで最後に 人が言うならば
アサンモーハダンモーサットローキーウッカンノ
混乱しない ボケない人が世の中で現れたと言うならば
バフジャナヒタすべての生命のために
すべての生命の幸福のために
みんなのことを憐れんで
みんなのことを助けてあげるために人が生まれるというならば
マメワタンサッマーワダマーノワデイ
それは私のことだよと
その時ははっきりとママ私ということを使っているのです
普通は如来という風に書かれますけど
もうお年でしょうし もう飽きちゃったんです
もううるさいと言ってやるぞ
何者なのかと 私のことだよと
世の中に人々のこと完璧に憐れんで
すべての生命に明確に幸福の道ってこれだよとわかりやすく具体的に教えて諭して
苦しみをなくしてあげる人といえば
これは私のことだよと
いて それでお釈迦様がまじをするんです
これ以上言えることはないんだから
だからスナッカッタさんの話はもう置いとかけらもなく
それを聞いたらお釈迦様はね
空気を送っていたんですよ
ナーガサマーラというまああるお坊さんが
これもお釈迦様の親戚の人なんです
だいたい身の回りの面倒見てのはほとんどみんなお釈迦様の親戚なんです
で 毛が立ちましたと 話を聞いて
これを本当に原文で読むと毛が立ちますよ
あまりにも迫力 パーリ語以外はもう他の言語に訳できんぐらいインパクトなんです
...ないんですよ 他の言語でこんな大胆に表現できる言葉っていうのは
ナーガサマナ長老っていうのはまたもう阿羅漢なんですけど
だから親戚だから いろいろごちゃごちゃ冗談言ったり
いろんなことを話したりするんですよ
だからお釈迦様の親戚しかあまり側近ではいないんです
あまりにもそれを言いながら
だから この昔からの知ってる親戚の人々がお釈迦様の周りに一緒にいるんです
で ナーガサマナ長老がお釈迦様に毛が立ちましたよと
いや 鳥肌が立ちましたよと
この経典はどういう経典で覚えればいいんですか？だったら鳥肌が立つ経典だと覚えておいてください
そういう感じ  言っても別にお釈迦様は気にしていないという
ただ ただ言っただけっていう感じなんです
あの馬鹿があんなこと言うんだから
私はただ言っただけだと
そんなに気にするだけないんだけど
だったら経典の名前は鳥肌が立つ経典だと覚えておいてください
で そういうことで お釈迦様っていうのはいかに偉大で
いかに絶対絶対的に乗り越えられません
等しいものはいません
それぐらい能力があって
私たちにはあんなにわかりやすい
あれほど明確なことを言ってるんですよ
それぐらい守れないというならば何者ですかね
自慢にできますかね 例えば富士山ぐらいの鎮火の山が自分のところにある
自分のもの お腹が空いたね
おにぎり一個食べたいんだけど
お金がないなとかね 言うならば立派
クレジットカードといえば
プラチナム プラチナムのゴールドカードではなくて
プラチナムカードを持っていると
あまりないんですけど
プラチナカードを持ってる人々っていうのは
持っていて お金がないな
何か食べてこりたいんだけどとかね
って言うならば それは立派ですか？その生き方
それで逆にちょっと百円ちょうだい
食い物がなくてお腹が空いているというならば
どれほど情けないと思いますかね
ポケットにプラチナムカードを持っているのに
ということは それぐらい財産があるということでしょ
銀行は家に呼べる人々でしょ
プラチナムカードっていうのは
会社が特別に選んだ人々に会社が勝手に配るものです
それでその人がそれなのにちょっと百円ちょうだい
お腹がすいたって言うと
かっこいいんですかね
皆様というか 世界の人間やってるのはそういうことなんです
だからお釈迦様の贈り物というのは並大抵のものじゃないんですよ
だからこの生命の憲法を定めているんです
それは誰にももうそう違うと言えることはできない
それで憲法があると私たちには生きやすいんですよ
生活しやすいんです だからまあそこは理解しておきましょうと
みんな文句を言いたい気持ちはわかるんだけど
もうブッダの立場はそういう立場なんです
そこでよく俗世間で言っていることっていうのは
やってみなきゃわからないと
ちょっとひどい目に遭わなきゃもう理解しないだろうと
それで真理を知り尽くすために
我々はどれぐらいひどい目に遭えばいいんですかね
例えば人殺さなきゃ人殺し屋の苦しみがわからないんだと
で それで人殺す 銀行強盗っていうのはどれほど怖いものかと
強盗はどれほど怖いものかと知るために
経験するために強盗をやってみるんですかね
だから これも愚かな人々の考え方ですよ
経験しなきゃわからないんだよと
こんなことできる？時間ある？人を殺してみて
それを味わってみて やっぱりこれが嫌
これから人を殺しませんとか
それ人生は成功できますかね
それでいろんな人々は
いや ヨガもやってみなくちゃ
あれもやってみなくちゃ
あのお経もやってみなくちゃとか
なんで不安定な不確定な曖昧なことをやってみなくちゃ
やってみなくちゃ言うんですかね
はっきりとチャレンジしてるものをやってみればいい
お釈迦様も一日だけでもやってみなさいと
結果がなかったら言ってくださいと
でも他の教えだったら死後でしょ
ヒンドゥ教であろうが
イスラムであろうが キリスト教であろうが
ジャイナ教であろうが
すべて死後の話なんですよ
それでやってみて 死ぬまでわからないでしょうね
死んだっても 西洋の宗教だったら最後の審判があるんだから
また待たなくちゃあかんでしょうに
見る限りわかるでしょ
その人々はただ人類のことだけしか見てないんだと
人類はいつか破壊するぞと
それで教え全部終わっちゃうんです
仏教はそうじゃなくて
破壊してもまた次から次と無限に宇宙が構成されて壊れて構成されて壊れてという
きりがないんだよと言ってる
現在喋ってるんだから
ですから このお釈迦様があれほど喋ってるのに
まあすぐ一日二日でわかりますよという風に言ってるんだから
だからやっぱりやっぱりいい加減やった方がいいということになるんです
で なんでそういうことを言いますかというと
我々には暇がないんですよ
イスラム教もやってみて
ヒンドゥー教もやってみてと
そんな余裕 暇がないんですよ
どうせ見たらもう曖昧ってことわかるでしょうに
将来の約束でしょうに
そこで嘘を言わなきゃ嘘の苦しみがわからないんだとかね
そんなことを言っちゃうと
我々はすべて経験しなくちゃいけないということになります
そんな経験できないということは明らかでしょうに
人殺しにしたっても 人一人殺しちゃうとね
まあそれで終わりでしょうね
人生は どこかで一回嘘をついて人を騙しちゃうと
まあそれっきり誰も信頼しないでしょうに
あれ試しにやったんだよと言ったら
それ自体で自分の人生認められませんでしょうに
だからもうこの我々の偉そうな経験主義をやめた方がいいですよ
潔くお釈迦様がおっしゃったようにやってみた方が確実に幸せになります
例えば私が結婚しなきゃ
結婚の生活をブッダが大変だと言ってますけど
自分で経験しなきゃといって試しに結婚できますかね
例えば若い時でも それで私はちょっと試すために家庭作りたいとわかったら
その女がどうしますかね
私に対して お前の実験じゃないじゃないんだと
言うでしょう そこで試しに子供を作ってみて
やっぱりうるさい 出家するそう
お釈迦様がおっしゃった通りやと
そんなこと言いますかね
だから人間にはそんな暇がない
命は短い いつ死ぬかわからない
だから究極な専門家の言う通りにする
飛行機に乗りたければ
自分で学校に入って 力学いろいろくだらんことを勉強して
それからそういうパイロット訓練場に入って
それから訓練を受けて
やっと合格して そこで飛行機に乗る
そんな成り立ちますかね
そういうパイロット養成所に
もう千人の人々が入学しようと試験を受けて
もう受かるのはもう十人ぐらいでしょうに
その中で訓練所をみんな落とすでしょう
だから経験主義っていうのはね
無知な人を言う経験主義っていうのはもうどうでもいいんです
そんなのは 仏教も経験主義ですけど
皆様の経験主義は見て認めません
それで飛行機に乗りたければ
長い間この科学的に知り尽くして研究をし尽くして
実験やりたい放題やってやってできてる飛行機あるでしょうに
それにはものすごい上手なパイロットたちが日々訓練を受けてやってるんだから
こっちは楽々に 4万円払って 2日間のハワイ旅をすればいいでしょうに
ホテル代も全く含むですから
だからどちらが理性的ですかね
どこかで 4万円で まあ大体 4万
5万でもう行けるぐらい安いものありますから
やっぱり私はそれは嫌やと
自分で飛行機の訓練を受けるぞという
ということだから 経験主義は
この即席の経験主義はあまり仏教ではないんです
で なんでそんな話をしたかというと
ブッダのそういう贈り物ですと
ブッダはそういう人ですと
だから人は騙すということはしない
絶対人を幸福に導く 憲法
人生の憲法 生命のあるべき姿を描ける
言える 証明する憲法定めることできるのはたった一人だよと
これがお釈迦様なんです
ということです ブッダの教えほど明確に教えている言葉っていうのは
人類には未だに作ることができなかったんです
皆様大変ありがたがっている
すごい素晴らしい方いるでしょ
日本で宮沢賢治です うん
もちろんブッダのインスピレーションでしょ
法華経とかね ちゃんと頭おかしい人がちょっとインスピレーションを受けただけで
どれほどかっこいい作品書くんですかね
あんなくだらぬ妄想するのは相当なもんですけどね
まあ作家っていうのは妄想しなきゃ作品成り立ちませんだけど
でもその中ででも人間にも勇気付けて
明るくしてあげて これが道だと言ってるんだから
だったら本物はどうだと思いますかね
法華経も本物じゃないんだからね
あれはインチキ教だから
でもブッダからインスピレーションを受けていることだけは確かなんです
そういうことだから ブッダの贈り物っていうのはブッダの教えなんです
それもあげたいんだからあげたわけじゃないんです
まあしょうがないと 持っていけと
いうふうにまあくれたものだから
我々は大事にしなくちゃいけない
そちらへんもお釈迦様がすごく智慧があるんですよ
あんた方に教えた教えるんだから聞いたかというと聞いちゃったと言っちゃうと
こっちは いらんということを言えるんです
教えたくないんだと あげたくないんだと
断りますと言ったところで
こちらで請願してもらったものだから
教えは 今更ケチをつける権利はないんです
せっかく無料でもらったものだから
大事に守るしかないんだよっていうことなんです
ということで 話を終了いたします
どうもありがとうございます
あ 終了する前にまだたくさんこちらに残っています
ポイント じゃあポイントだけいきます
人間の問題っていうのは
これは全く違いますけど
言われるままに生きる
ブッダはそれ嫌なんですよ
自分の幸福概念さえも他人に教わったもの
ろくなものじゃない 誰かに言われたものですし
幸福と思っているのは
それで感情で判断する
行動する 考えて行動する
行ったことを覚えがないんです
それで成功するか失敗するか分からない
我々は 先を心配して生きている人間っていうのは
満たされてないままで死ぬ
これが人間の生き方なんです
はい 次 ただ 人間に必要なものは何なのかというと
善悪の判断能力 言われてもらうままに生きるんじゃなくて
これが悪い これがいいとはっきり知ること
幸福とは何かと理解すること
人に言ったことじゃなくて
人間にとって幸福って何かと自分で理解しなくちゃいけない
理性に基づき具体的に判断する
行動する 感情で生きているんじゃなくて
ちゃんと理性で考えて生きてほしい
確実に成功を収める 成功するか失敗するか
それやってみなきゃわからないでは生き方ダメですよ
はっきりとこれで成功するんだよという風に計画を立てて生きていなくちゃいけないんです
心配のない穏やかな生き方をしなくちゃいけないんです
先を心配する必要ない
満たされた気持ち 充実した生き方
これがお釈迦様が教えている道なんです
はい 次 それが何なのかということはあり終わったんだけど
八正道なんですよ あれの項目聞くとなんか知り込みしたくなるでしょ
満たされた生き方 幸福の定義と
でも八正道ですよ わかりやすく教えてるんです
八正道実践すれば これ知ってるし
皆様は 正見 正思惟 正語
なんとなんとかとかね
副作用一切ない生きる道
八正道っていうのは はい
次 生きている上では 闇雲にチャレンジするのではなく
何にチャレンジするのかとはっきりする
それは自分に必要かないか
これまた別な項目なんです
だから今日はもうまあ回ぐらいの講演のデータ持ってるんです
だから今日はまとめないといいから言ったんですからね
確かめる 利点を考察する
不点を考察する 実行しても我に合うかないかを調べる
それに依存しないで ちょっと間違いね
依存しない状態がある
依存しないでいられる状態があるのかと知る
我々はどのように生きること
はい やりましょうではなくて
この項目を考えてほしい
ただ闇雲に生きるんじゃないんですよ
何にチャレンジするのか
なんでチャレンジするのか
それが私にどうしても必要か
これの利点は何なのか
不点は何なのか とにかく実行して利点が出ても我に合っているか
あるいはそんなものはない生き方もあるのかというポイントが必要なんです
それは理性の生き方なんです
理性でそう言っても はい
これはチェックポイントといえばもっとわかりやすくしたんです
日本語でわからないんだったら
英語だったら明確です Whatineedwhyineedthishowicangetthis howcan
ですよ Howcanigetthis？
これ一つ間違ったら全部ウッパスで書くんだから間違ったんです
まあ英語的にはそんなに間違えても Howcanigetthis? どのように得られればいいか Whencanigetthis?
いつ得られるのかと どれぐらい時間かかりますか Whathaveigiveawaytoachievemyobjective?
私の目的に達するために
私は何を損しなくちゃいけない
いわゆる何といいますか
何か何か無くさなくちゃあかんでしょ
代償ですか  代償 何なのかと Isitworthwhile?
それでも価値があるのかと CanIlivewithoutit?
これがない生き方ないのかと
これちょっとちょっと微妙なポイントで必要になったんだから必要なんですよ
それで別の生き方はないんでしょうかと考えなくちゃいけない
...Is there any path that I could be free from it?それで
この この必要が今あるんだけど
これを必要としない別な道方道あるんでしょうかと考えなければいけないんです
あまり分かりきっていることだから
次に行きます これで終わりと思います
[笑い] 一応 我々はそういうポイントを考えて生きなさいとお釈迦様は徹底的に教えているんです
闇雲にものに飛び出すんじゃなくて
考えてみなさいと 必要がないかと
非天不天と同じ それから道方法
それで何かやるためには何か代償なんですよ
それで割に合うかないか
では そういうあれ欲しいこれ欲しいという生き方乗り越えて関係ない
まるっきり別な次元の生き方ないのか
それ働かせちゃうと もう減ったでしょ
やっぱり怠け者 やりたくないんだから
自分が怠け者って言わないで仏教は嫌いと言うんですよ
これには怒らせる怒らないでいる我々もよっぽど鈍感だと思いますよ
だからみんなこの仏教に対して悪口
悪口は言ったり 批判したりするのは
これはブッダの教えに対してじゃないんですよ
自分の情けない状況を堂々と発表しているんです
それだけです 学者の方々も
ブッダは煩悩なくなってないんだとあれほど言っているのにというのは
まあ自分の未熟さ 論理性に欠けているところ
科学的じゃないこと研究は表しているんです
いわゆる自分で自分の首をチョン切っているんです
ということで じゃあ話は省略します
今度は本気で省略します
ありがとうございます
[笑い] お釈迦様に会えない民族
仏教者でなかったら幸せにならない
[笑い] あの このはすごい具体的ね
お釈迦様は人間でしょうし
だからブッダのメッセージはね
どれどれまで広げるかっていうね
人間の世界では制限がありますからね
だから観念的なことを言ってもあまり意味がないんですよ
だから我々は だから我々は死ぬ思いで頑張っているんですよ
もう頑張らなくちゃいけないんですよ
もう あの あの人はあまり性格悪いんだから
あの人は生きづらいんだからとか
わがままなくて やっぱりもうもう死ぬ瞬間まで
だから宣伝文句にあったでしょ
仏弟子たちも本当にもう死ぬ瞬間までブッダも弟子たちも頑張ったんですよ
このメッセージを教えるために
だから今もそれなりの仏教をわかっているお坊さんたちやら
みんながもう必死で頑張ってはいるんです
それしかやることないんですよ
だから このただよく食べているんだとかね
自然に恵まれているとかね
それぐらいのことは言えますけど
例えば 南アフリカの森ありますね
熱帯のすごい巨大な森とかね
そういうところで もう文明とは関係なく幸せでいるんだと
でもそれだけでは十分でしょうかね
人生っていうのはね だからブッダに会わなかった人は幸せか幸福かっていうと
ちょっとそれはややこしいんですけどね
まあただ食べてはいるかもしれませんだけど
真理の発見というのはできないんですね
やっぱり曖昧で生きることになります
怯えて生きることになります
ブッダに会ったなら ブッダの教えに出会ったならば
もう曖昧でも何ともなく
ニコニコとしっかり生きることができます
ですから  そういう話 答えになります
しかし 人誰でも法則だからね
道を発見すれば大丈夫なんですよ
ブッダがブッダに会わなくても
現代社会では 人間にはこれそんな能力はないんです
今 日本では流行っている
このジェームス・アレンという人の本がありますね
アースマンティンカーという英語の言葉
なんていうん 原因と結果の法則とか
素晴らしい本でしょ やっぱりすごい昔
百年ともっと前にブッダの話に出会って
本人がちゃんとそれを理解して修行までしてわかったんですよ
これ あ これやと 人間を成功させる法則は
だから彼の本は聖書よりもたくさん読まれているんだとか
データはないんですけど
言われていますけど では
彼がなんであんなに淡々と
あれほどわかりやすく
人間を驚かせるほどの真理を語れるかというと
やっぱりブッダの教えなんですよ
本人一人では発見できないでしょうし
そういうことだから難しいですよ
無理ということではなくて
難しいということです
その本の最初はダンマパダの一と二が原典になっているんです
今おっしゃった原因と結果の
最近ベストセラーの中に一つ入っているんですけど
ダンマパダの引用っていうふうにはなってないんですけど
文句は全部同じですね
そこでこの本の真ん中の方も
経典で書いているものは見事に集約して入れているんです
例えば欲といわゆる嫉妬するとこんなものになるんだとか
怠けるとこんなものになるんだとかね
自分も社会環境もこういうふうに変わるんだぞとかね
こいつはよくやるなと思って私も感心するんですよ
こんな一行二行でよくこいつと言ったらすごい失礼な方ですけど
なぜならば その人は本物だからね
自分で経験しないとあれできませんよ
だから自分でブッダの真理を経験しているんだっていうことはもう明確
だからもう驚くというぐらいですよ
わかりやすく言ってるしね
だからダンマパダだけじゃなくて
結構立ち下がっています
はい また  今の本は私も買っていたので
もう少し詳しく書きたいと思うので紹介してください
書いて出して じゃあスクリーンに映ります
ちょっと待ってください
機械は遅いんです 人間よりも
こちらで書けばそれだけのことですけど
サンマークっていう版です
先生の本で 値段はちょっと忘れますけど
うん うん 私は持っていると思います
じゃあ原文が何でしたっけ？あります
この本です  いくらですか
えーと 税なしで千二百円です
この人は立派な人だから
これ誰でも日本訳したっても何訳したってもいいんです
再販したっても何でもいいんです
自由です  そうですね では
どうしますか？ 瞑想のことで聞きたいんですけど
立つ瞑想で目の置き所ってどこら辺に
例えば壁の前に立ってるんだったら
壁の方を見ているか だったら下を見ていくとかね
立つ瞑想はあまり目を意識しないということが大事なんですね
ジロジロジロジロと見ちゃうと集中力が乱れちゃうんですね
だからできるだけ足 足に集中する
目を閉じてはいける  閉じちゃうと倒れる可能性あります
で 人間二本の足だから二本の足で倒れるんですよ
三本でないと この三本目目なんですよ
みんなわかってないだけで
二本足で立ってるわけじゃないんです
ちゃんと三本で立ってる
だから目は三本目の足ですよ
だからそれだけの仕事をしてもらう
もう一つ 座る瞑想で待つ状態でいると
呼吸を観察していると口に唾が溜まる
それに気づいて飲みたいと思った時に
今自分が言葉をかけるというのは
口に唾があります 喉に入りますって感じで観察っていうか
言葉をやってるんですけど
そういう感じでいいんですか？ まあ悪く悪くはないしね
まあ単純でも実況実況する必要ありますね
飲みたい 飲み込みます
それぐらいでね  うん それでまた呼吸に
呼吸に戻る時には戻りますって声をかけた方がいいですか？ まあそれはなくてもいいんです
うん  はい 一番目のスライドでそのいつも思うんですけども
どうしてその聖者のその心の働きっていうのが地理的なレンジを持ってしまうのかっていうのがよくわからないんですけど
機械とか物理現象だったら
例えば R の 2乗分の 1っていう風に
こう 距離が離れるとだんだん力が弱くなっていくっていうのはわかるんですけど
心の働きっていうのは距離に
わけ簡単です 物質は心が作っているんだからね
でもその聖者から安定させる心の作用っていうのは
個々の生物に働きかけるときに
原理簡単でしょうに 一切の物質は心が支配者で
心が作ってるんでしょうに
だからもうこれで支配者が自分で作ってるんだから
関係は あの本を読んでみてください
科学とはもっと科学はもうあの子供遊びですからね
まるっきり間違ってる時点に立ってやってるでしょうに
だから科学の法則だったら
その距離が  それはわかりますね
それがなぜ心の働きだ
距離が離れ  仏教の場合はその科学的実験ではなくて
心がものを創るんだというところですから
離れても別にそんなに強さは変わらないんだったら
別にその村とか平地とか谷とかっていうのを限定しなくても
聖者がいれば  そこでなんで決めたかというと
人間の電波が届く範囲なんですね
例えばインドに至ってもいいんだけど
我々はそこまでは気持ちはいかないでしょ
だから... だから聖者がいる
凡夫の私が聖者の恩恵を受けるでしょ
そこで凡夫の私の気持ちがどこまで広げるかっていうことでリミットが定められるんです
だから聖者がその心の働きを出した時に
それを受ける側の受信機の機能っていうのは関係ないわけですか
だから  いえ それだったら神様みたいな感じで一方的になるんですよ
聖者には人に電波を出す気持ちは全然ないんで
聖者は自分で穏やかで気持ちよくいるだけ
そこで凡人がその範囲に行けばすぐ繋げる
しかし だから一般人の人だったら
あ うちの村にはすごい人がいるんだぞという話で終わっちゃいます
しかし イギリスでもその聖者のことを知っている人がいるならば
その人にとってはそれでもその影響はあるんです
人の能力なの 受ける側の
じゃあ例えばその 今衛星チャンネルとかありますけど
こういうお坊さんチャンネルみたいなのを作って
[笑い]それは物理的なことだからね
それは関係ないんですよ
今のこの現在で言えば
インターネットでつながっていれば
そのページを見に行く人は影響を受けるっていうような感覚で
その当時だったらお坊さんのところにいて
お坊さんがその聖者の雰囲気を作ってるんだけど
その聖者は確認した人だけが影響を受けるから
その村だけ  そういうふうなものになります
それから この 각각人間には物質的な体を持っていますから
どれぐらいの威力とインパクトを広げるかということを
やっぱりその馬力によりますよ
悟っ- 感知能力  いわゆる発生する能力もそのその人により違います
例えば サーリプッタ尊者の能力とモクレン尊者の能力はまるっきり同一ではないんです
で 全然そういう発生しない阿羅漢たちもいます
エネルギーが そこでシャッターをついて悟ったら
全部シャッとオフして
普通にいるという 全くも感じないようにするということもあります
知らせません 誰にも 感じもさせませんという
いろいろ ブッダの時代ではそれをやらせなかったんです
落ち着いていさせなかったと
お釈迦様は 頑張りなさいと
みんなのためにと 蹴っ飛ばしちゃいますから
だからまあ そこで悟った方々は誰々かとみんな知っている
言わなくたってお釈迦様が言う
こんな問題だったらあなたでしょうとか
堂々と言う こういう問題解決あなたでしょうと
あなた黙ってて誰がやるんですかと
サーリプッタ尊者結構怒られましたからね
ある若いお坊さんたちがすごいだらしない
もう乱暴な生き方をして
お坊さんたちがおびえちゃったんです
あまりにも乱暴だから
でお釈迦様に報告入っちゃって
あの村はダメやと 村人までダメになってるんだと
だから他のお坊さんたち誰かが行って躾すればどうですかと
それでお坊さんたちはもう怖いと
いけませんと 送る人がないんですね
お釈迦様はサーリプッタ
あれあなたの弟子たちでしょう
結局は  [笑い]だけど
出家すればみんなもう一応サーリプッタ尊者の弟子っていうことになるんだから
かわいそうなんですけど
[笑い]あなたの弟子たちでしょ
行きなさい それだけ だからもうサーリプッタ尊者そこではい
わかりましたと すごい謙虚な方でしたけど
ああいう風に言われると一言も釈迦像に逆らえませんだから
お釈迦様に言われたら
はい ではやらせていただきますということで行くんです
ということだから このブッダの時代ではね
ちゃんと力を発揮していましたけど
まあどんどんどんどんそんなにやらなかったんですけどね
そこら辺のはまあ一応別にどうでもいい話といえばどうでもいいことですからね
一応聖者がいる場所は極楽なんです
今もね お釈迦様が生まれた場所やらね
悟ったところやら 今も聖地なんですよ
すごい聖地なんです なのになんでインド富豪かというと
バカにしているんだからなんです
その場所というのは やったらいけないんですよ
すごいふさわしく 尊い風に
そのやらないと 国にとっても良くないんです
でも 仏教徒たちがこういうところにいたら夢中になるんです
我を普通忘れるんです
すごい感じるんです そこで
あ ブッダだと 何のこともなく
だからまあ大変なかなかなもんですけど
お釈迦様が涅槃に入ったところに行って
信者さんが行ったり来たりだから
みんな見る機会ないんだけど
私もあんまり見てないんですけど
みんなから話を聞くんだけど
来る来る人がなるんですよ
瞬時に再現するんですよ
なんとなく精神的に 見えるわけじゃないんだけど
お釈迦様が最後に息を引き取ること
この その状況とか風景というか
いても立ってもいられなくなるんですよ
ただいただけで すごいもう心がもう狂ったかな
だからそういうのはやっぱりこの心は支配者だから
そちらは仏陀の心は働いている
はい